thorsten frei jetzt für die union und
sie den überwiegenden teil ihrer rede
zeit darauf verwenden die koalition die
opposition zu beschimpfen das ist
sicherlich keine zukunftsträchtige
strategie wenn es darum geht die
herausforderungen der zukunft zu lösen
und zu bewältigen und in der tat es sind
wichtige zeiten in denen wir stehen es
gibt ereignisse die zeilen die zeit in
ein davor und ein danach und der
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg russlands
auf die ukraine ist ein solches ereignis
und deswegen hatte herr bundeskanzler
heute ja auch sehr viel über die
zeitenwende der großen staaten
gesprochen es gibt aber zeitgleich auch
eine zeitenwende der kleinen leute und
die beginnt nicht mit einer
kriegserklärung sondern die kommt
schleichend und lautlos daher wie ist
unerbittlich und sie ist enttäuschend
für viele menschen und auch
existenzbedrohlich und diese zeitenwende
macht vor allen dingen rentner arbeiter
und sparer zu den großen verlierern
dieser zeit und diese zeitenwende heißt
inflation und sie
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
antworten darauf nur mit dem kurieren
von symptomen nicht indem sie die
ursachen der inflation der
geldentwertung bekämpfen und sie herr
bundeskanzler haben heute morgen gelobt
wie die rentensteigerung ausfallen wird
ja wir hatten im letzten jahr eine
geldentwertung von 3,1 prozent in diesem
jahr von 7,9 prozent das sind mehr als
zwei prozent als die rentensteigerung
die wir dieses jahr bekommen werden das
heißt nicht mehr für die menschen
sondern weniger in den geldbeuteln das
ist die wahrheit und darauf sollten sie
eine antwort finden in dieser situation
in dieser situation die gebe ich ihnen
gerne in dieser situation sind vor allen
dingen diejenigen getroffen die den
ratschlag vieler politiker in den
vergangenen jahren beherzigt haben
nämlich fürs alter vorzusorgen
aber in dieser situation
die altersvorsorge der menschen hier in
deutschland wie eis in der sonne das ist
das ergebnis ihrer politik und ich will
an dieser stelle ich will an dieser
stelle meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren auch von den grünen ich will an
dieser stelle einmal den früheren
bundesfinanzminister
zitieren der hat nämlich im juni letzten
jahres also vor ziemlich genau einem
jahr folgenden satz gesagt zitat ich
will allen die sorge nehmen dass wir mit
der inflation ein allzu großes problem
bekommen die inflation wird viel
geringer und ganz normal ausfallen als
viele befürchten das hat der damalige
bundesfinanzminister vor einem jahr
gesagt und ich will ihnen nicht
vorwerfen dass sie anders als andere die
herr aufkommenden probleme nicht erkannt
haben dass sie sie denkt geschwiegen
haben aber was ihnen vorzuwerfen ist ist
dass sie bis heute es nicht als zentrale
herausforderung ihrer kanzlerschaft
begriffen haben etwas dagegen zu tun
dass das geld der menschen mehr und mehr
entwertet wird das ist die
herausforderung wenn sie es täten dann
würden sie eine andere fiskalpolitik
machen dann würden sie insbesondere auf
europäischer ebene nach anderen regeln
rufen sie tun das allerdings nicht und
deswegen sage ich ihnen eines der kampf
gegen die geldentwertung das ist
sozialer verantwortung der kampf gegen
die geldentwertung das ist
leistungsgerechtigkeit und deswegen
fordern wir sie auf endlich dieses thema
auch anzugehen und zwar nicht
indem man an den symptomen herumdoktern
sondern indem man die ursachen bekämpft
und ich will vor diesem hintergrund noch
ein letztes zitat heute ansprechen es
stammt vom früheren
oppositionspolitiker und heutigen
finanzminister christian lindner er hat
damals über die inflation die er früher
als andere erkannt hat und den damaligen
bundesfinanzminister folgendes gesagt
zitat der staat attackiert lindner
scholz den er mit einem karnevalsprinzen
vergleicht ist einer der größten wenn
ich der größte treiber vom platz als
finanzminister war olaf scholz mit
kamelle um sich und weiter die
öffentlichen finanzen solide zu halten
ist der wesentliche baustein der
inflationsbekämpfung wenn die ezb das
schlepptau der fiskalpolitik stark
verschuldeter staaten geraten würde dann
hätte sie kaum eine möglichkeit die
inflation zu bekämpfen
zitat ende und statt neuer schulden
müsste deutschland so lindner den zitat
tilgungsfonds anwerfen also unsolide
staatsfinanzen schmettert lindner scholz
entgegen gefährten die preisstabilität
ich finde besser kann man es nicht
zusammenfassen und umso mehr fragt man
sich ob das wirklich der mann ist der
sechs monate später einen
verfassungswidrigen
nachtragshaushalt mit 60 milliarden
neuen schulden vorlegt wie ganz sicher
auch vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht
scheitern werden ob das der gleiche mann
ist der zwölf monate später mit 240
milliarden euro nettoneuverschuldung die
höchste neuverschuldung in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland zu verantworten hat meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren ich will
ihnen sagen es gibt etwas das schmilzt
noch schneller als das vermögen der
deutschen
und das ist die glaubwürdigkeit der fdp
sie schmilzt das eis in der sonne meine
sehr verehrten damen und
und vor diesem hintergrund stellt sich
wirklich die frage
wir haben ein bundeskanzler der regiert
das problem und tut auch jetzt so als
gäbe es nicht wir haben ein
bundesfinanzminister der erkenntnis
problem handelt aber gegensätzlich und
damit wird eines deutlich es ist das
muster ihrer koalition diese koalition
wird zusammengehalten durch schulden
schulden und noch mehr schulden es ist
der kitt dieser koalition damit wird
alles zugeschüttet aber was vielleicht
der zement für diese koalition ist es
sprengstoff für die glaubwürdigkeit der
fdp es sollten sie sich sehr gut
überlegen
und jetzt muss man jetzt muss man eines
sagen
in der einen oder anderen rede hat man
den eindruck gewinnen können dass
geldentwertung
schicksal wäre eine naturgewalt nein das
ist es nicht
die geldentwertung ist das ergebnis
politischer ökonomischer fiskalische und
geldpolitische entscheidungen und jeder
einzelne dieser entscheidung kann man
auch anders treffen und ich will es
ihnen an drei beispielen benennen ja ich
werde interessant drei beispielen
benehmen natürlich stimmt es dass wir
den lock down in china haben dass wir
den krieg in der ukraine haben da haben
sie vollkommen recht dass wir eine die
lokalisierung von produktionsstätten
haben dass wir die fiskalpolitik der
staaten haben und die geldpolitik der
europäischen zentralbank aber an drei
beispielen möchte ich ihnen zeigen dass
man es auch anders machen kann erstens
die verlagerung von produktionsstätten
ja es ist richtig sich aus russland
zurück zu ziehen und es ist auch richtig
in den blick zu nehmen dass wir
strategische abhängigkeiten von china
reduzieren oder gar beenden aber wenn
man das tut dann muss eine
internationalisierte volkswirtschaft wie
wir sie haben auch nach neuen räumen
ausschau halten und das bedeutet noch
mehr internationale zusammenarbeit mit
den staaten die unsere werte von
freiheit von demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit teilen dann geht es
um staaten wie die usa und kanada und
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
sieht es seit vier jahren ausverhandelt
ist ausgeurteilt vom
bundesverfassungsgericht seit wochen
bemühen wir uns in jeder einzelnen
sitzungswoche das ratifizierungsgesetz
sicher im bundestag zur abstimmung zu
bringen
wer verhindert es die koalition
verhindert ist und es macht sie
unglaubwürdig meines rtr herr kollege
einheiten für einen zweiten punkt will
ich anspreche kollege feiere ich habe
die uhr angehalten gestatten sie eine
frage das heißt ich hatte sie angehalten
wir starten sie eine frage oder
bemerkungen aus der grünen fraktion
lieber herr frey wir haben uns ja auch
letzte woche schon 40 minuten zum thema
inflation ausgetauscht und ich finde es
schön dass sie jetzt auch nicht nur die
symptome bekämpfen wollen sondern die
ursachen angehen wollen ganz
unumstritten liegen die ursachen an
unserer massiven klumpenrisiko haften
abhängigkeit von russischem gas die sie
uns hinterlassen haben 55% abhängigkeit
das muss man erstmal schaffen da sind
jetzt dran das zu lösen zweitens
energiemärkte die auch vom bmf und
kartellamt als populistisch bezeichnet
werden angebot und nachfrage regeln hier
eben nicht den preis ich wünsche mir
jetzt sie haben vor fünf minuten schon
gefragt dass sie uns damals lösungen
präsentieren da haben sie gesagt sie
wollen das machen bitte nennen sie uns
doch mal ihre lösungen für den
energiemarkt und dass diese preise die
übrigens auch ursachen für die
lebensmittelpreise in deutschland sind
und zwar massiv dass sie die das
auflösen würden was sie uns 16 jahre
kaputt gemacht haben vielen dank
bleiben sie bisher in
sehr geehrte frau beck einen punkt habe
ich gerade eben erwähnt wenn es
beispielsweise um internationale
handelsverträge geht den zweiten punkt
will ich gerne ansprechen das ist auch
ein wesentlicher grund für die ursachen
für die ursachen der geldentwertung das
ist der angebotsschock den wir in europa
haben darauf hat übrigens die
europäische kommission reagiert indem
sie ermöglicht dass wir beispielsweise
auch beispielsweise auch aus
ökologischen brachflächen vorrangflächen
feldfrüchte anbauen können da könnte man
allein in deutschland
800.000 tonnen getreide anbauen mit
denen man drei millionen menschen
ernähren könnte alle länder in europa
aktivierendes einer ist dagegen herr
bundeskanzler ist das tier
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister und
deswegen muss man sagen das ist nicht
nur ein beitrag um die probleme noch
weiter zu verschärfen sondern dass es
auch ein beitrag dazu nichts zu leisten
wenn es darum geht eine weltweite
hungersnot zu bekämpfen und ich will
einen
[Applaus]
vorweg sie haben ganz konkret sie haben
ganz konkretes thema energie
angesprochen
ich frage mich wenn ich ihre pläne hier
im deutschen bundestag anschaut da ist
zum beispiel auch das oster paket dabei
ich bin ein abgeordneter aus dem schwarz
weiter gibt es seit jahrhunderten
wasserkraft wasserkraft versorgt etwa
eine million haushalte in deutschland
mit energie regenerative energie die
aber anders als wind und sonne dann zur
verfügung steht wenn man sie wirklich
braucht und im ostpaket sind regelungen
drin die wasserkraftwerke für 90 prozent
der betreiber verunmöglichen und es
machen sie in einer zeit wo es darum
geht autark zu werden wo es darum geht
unabhängig zu werten da nehmen sie diese
möglichkeiten vom tisch genauso wie die
wie sie die letzten drei verbliebenen
atomkraftwerke ausgerechnet an dem tag
abschalten wollen wo wir wahrscheinlich
den peak der herausforderungen im
nächsten winter erreichen werden das ist
sicherlich keine kluge und
verantwortungsvolle politik und ich will
zum dritten sagten
natürlich ist für inflation vor allen
dingen auch die geldpolitik der
europäischen zentralbank entscheidend
dies ist unabhängig zu recht aber die
spielräume der europäischen zentralbank
die selbst in zeiten dieser inflation
noch negative einlagenzinsen und
anleihekäufe macht die dieser
handlungsspielraum ergibt sich natürlich
auch daraus wie die fiskalpolitik der
staaten aussieht und da würde ich mir
wirklich versprechen dass sie einer
sicherheitspolitischen zeitenwende auch
eine haushalts- und finanzpolitische
zeitenwende folgen lassen dass sie
schwerpunkte setzen und dass sie nicht
jedes problem mit neuen schulden lösen
womit wir natürlich dann auch eine
negative vorbildwirkung in ganz europa
haben werden und dafür bräuchten wir
einen starken
bundesfinanzminister der als liberaler
eigentlich die ganzen linken
blütenträume aus dem koalitionsvertrag
herausstreichen müsste und dazu
bräuchten wir einen bundeskanzler der in
diesem zusammenhang nicht von einem
hamilton moment träumt der bundeskanzler
sie haben damals nicht die ganze
geschichte erzählt als es um die
verschuldung in europa ging als
alexander hamilton
1790 die vergemeinschaftung der schulden
in den usa
ermöglicht hat da hat er im grunde
genommen nicht den zement für den neuen
staat angehört sondern er hat
sprengstoff gelegt er hat viele staaten
in die insolvenz getrieben das waren
auswirkungen bis zum amerikanischen
unabhängigkeitskrieg bis zum großen
krieg der staaten und es ist etwas das
wollen wir nicht schulden sind keine
zukunftspolitik in deutschland nicht und
in europa nicht und sie sollten eine
politik machen die dazu führt dass wir
auch in europa die regeln einhalten die
wir uns gegeben haben die es dann
ermöglichen dass wir tatsächlich auch
kraftvoll gegen inflation und
geldentwertung vorgehen können
herzlichen dank
thorsten frei parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
der bundestag debattiert am zweiten tag
der haushaltsdebatten hier in der
sogenannten generaldebatte
und der nächste redner wird von der spd
kommt achim post stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender
präsidentin meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ehrlich gesagt fragen sie nach den
beiden reden von herrn merz und herrn
frey den ich sehr schätze wie sie wissen
muss man eigentlich alles negieren was
man in 16 jahren regierungszeit gemacht
hat kann man auch regiert kann man auch
regieren dass man selbst für die größte
nettokreditaufnahme in diesem lande
bisher verantwortlich war und das jetzt
den anderen in die fugen weil man ihre
position ist ist das nicht vielleicht
ein bisschen wenig ist das nicht
vielleicht unterkomplex wenn die das
macht wagen nach
wenn wir über diesen haushalt reden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dann hat
diese ampel koalition diese
bundesregierung dieser
bundesfinanzminister
und die fraktionen diese ampel einen
haushalt vorgelegt einem guten haushalt
vorgelegt einen guten und
verantwortbaren haushalt vorgelegt und
dieser haushalt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ist auch dringend notwendig in
zeiten wie diesen denn mit diesem
haushalt gewährleistet diese koalition
diese bundesregierung dieser
bundeskanzler dieser
bundesfinanzminister dass wir es
hinbekommen was für die äußere
sicherheit für die innere sicherheit und
für diese zahle sich hat gleichzeitig zu
tun denn diese drei dinge gehören
zusammen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ja es stimmt
dieser haushalt hat ein volumen
495 milliarden euro das ist viel geld
das weiß ich es gibt gründe dafür ich
nenne mal ein paar der erste grund ist
die korona pandemie mit der wir uns seit
zwei jahren auseinander setzen müssen
und die noch nicht zu ende ist liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und die bei
erfordert dass wir betrieben und
beschäftigten helfen und diese koalition
wird das auch machen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und es gibt einen zweiten wurden
putins angriffskrieg der
auswirkung hat nicht nur für millionen
von menschen in der ukraine für viele
tote er hat auch auswirkungen auf uns
auf deutschland auf europa und auf die
welt und das ist keine petitesse liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sondern das ist
eine zeitenwende von der wir alle zu
recht hier geredet haben und deshalb
will ich mal eins sagen ich glaube das
ist richtig ist ich weiß dass es richtig
ist dass wir uns geeinigt haben in
dieser zeitenwende auf das
sondervermögen bundeswehr und zwar die
ampel zusammen mit der größten
oppositionsfraktion mit der cdu/csu und
ich weiß das zu schätzen dass wir
gemeinsam diese zeitenwende mit einer
antwort versehen nämlich mit einer
starken bundeswehr und wenn ich mal
etwas sagen darf zur kollegin mohammed
ali zur linken wenn sie willy brandt
zitieren das dürfen sie gerne machen das
den dürfen dort gern ändern dürfen alles
mit willy brandt machen was sie möchten
aber ich darf auch darauf antworten und
ich möchte darauf antworten willy brandt
ist der falsche kronzeuge gegen das
sondervermögen denn willy brandt hat den
friedensnobelpreis bekommen für eine
werte geleitete realpolitik mit der
aussöhnung mit dem osten mit mit der
suppe damaligen sowjetunion mit den
anderen ländern osteuropas und er diesen
friedensnobelpreis bekommen weil er das
gemacht hat auf der grundlage
einer starken verankerung in der nato im
westlichen bündnis und in der
europäischen union die bundeswehr hatte
damals 500.000 soldatinnen und soldaten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
also
keine falschen kronzeugen so
ich merke der kollege
holt sie wussten es
tut mir leid ich muss sie erstmal
geschäftsleitung eingreifen sind sie
bereit eine frage oder bemerkung des
kollegen in horten zu bekommen
danke
kollege dass wir das so die lateral
klären aber wir warten natürlich auf die
präsidentin ich möchte sie fragen weil
sie einen kurzen exkurs zu willy brandt
gemacht haben da wäre ja schon meine
frage wenn wir in die historie zurück
rücken insbesondere die
auseinandersetzung die auch der von mir
sehr verehrte willy brandt mit dem
nachfolger helmut schmidt geführt hat wo
es ja insbesondere um die aufrüstung
ging teilen sie meine einschätzung dass
willy brandt insbesondere für die
damalige friedensbewegung eine sehr
große rolle gespielt hat wo sich nämlich
explizit gegen die aufrüstung stark
gemacht hat unter anderem mit heinrich
böll und vielen anderen und deswegen
dazu meine frage finden sie deswegen
nicht das was meine
fraktionsvorsitzenden zurecht ausgeführt
hat dann doch historisch treffender als
das was sie gerade entgegnet haben
lieber kollege also ich weiß nicht ob
man es besser macht wenn man jetzt noch
einen anderen äpfel und birnen vergleich
hinzufügt ich glaube das eine mit dem
anderen nichts zu tun deswegen bedanke
ich mich für die zwischenfrage aber ich
glaube dass sie mehr oder weniger
sinnlos verschwenden
und jetzt kommen wir jetzt können wir
zum sondervermögen was ist das was ist
das gute am sonntag vermögen dass
deutschland das die bundesregierung
reagieren auf die zeitenwende dass wir
uns wehrhafter machen dass wir unsere
bundeswehr besser ausstatten und
gleichzeitig über die konstruktion des
sondervermögens dafür sorgen dass in
anderen bereichen waren klimaschutz in
der bildungspolitik in der sozialpolitik
nicht gekürzt wird liebe kolleginnen
kollegen und das ist ein ganz hohes gut
eingangstor wert das ist genau die
richtige politik
und das was ich gerade gesagt habe über
die politik von willy brandt und helmut
schmidt dass sie eingebettet ist ins
westliche bündnis das gilt doch auch für
die bundesrepublik deutschland das galt
auch schon zu zeiten hat sie regierte
haben lieber kollege und kollegen 100
cdu/csu und das gilt erst recht für
diese ampel koalition für diese
außenministerin für diesen bundeskanzler
vor diesem bundesfinanzminister und für
alle anderen die da sitzen denn das was
wir machen folgt einem grundmuster das
grundmuster heißt koordinierung und
kooperation wir koordinieren und
kooperieren innerhalb der europäischen
union innerhalb der nato und mit unseren
transatlantischen partnern und anderen
freundinnen und frauen in der welt und
genau das ist die richtige haltung um
außen und friedenspolitik zu machen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und wenn wir und wenn wir darüber reden
was wichtig ist für deutschland dann
würde ich auch mal gerne was sagen wir
müssen hier in deutschland darüber reden
dass wir natürlich wir haben über die
äußere und die innere sicherheit geredet
auch über die soziale sicherheit gerade
in zeiten wie diesen werden und ich
gucke mal rüber zur regierungsbank zu
wertlos heil ich kann für meine fraktion
mich nur bedanken beim
bundesarbeitsminister dafür dass er
zwölf euro mindestlohn einführt und das
ab dem ersten oktober millionen von
menschen von diesen mindestlohn
profitieren
und wenn ich das mache habe ich eine
frage an die kolleginnen und kollegen
von der cdu csu erst waren sie gegen den
mindestlohn ganz grundsätzlich immer
ganz grundsätzlich vor den letzten
landtagswahlen hatte ich den eindruck
sie waren dafür ich kenne auch viele
zitate
wo zum beispiel der jetzige
ministerpräsident wüst gesagt hat er sei
für die einführung eines mindestlohns
von 12 euro jetzt höre ich dass sie am
falter sich enthalten wollen was für ein
machtvolles dokument der hilflosigkeit
liebe kollegen und kollegen wunder
cdu-kollege post sie können natürlich
weiter sprechen ich mache aber überhaupt
aufmerksam dass sie das jetzt auf kosten
ihrer nachfolgenden kolleginnen und
kollegen tun da ich das dann sah ich
dass da ich das nie machen beende ich
meine rede mit einem ganz klaren hinweis
diese bundesregierung dieser
bundeskanzler diese ampel koalition sind
gut vor deutschland ich bin stolz darauf
dass olaf scholz unter bundeskanzler ist
und niemand der da vorne sitzt sollen
dank
achim post mit einer feststellung die
folgerichtig war den er
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der spd alles andere wäre ja auch sehr
wunderlich gewesen aber auch er hat
seine redezeit sehr strapaziert wie vor
ihm schon der bundeskanzler deswegen hat
er rolf mützenich aus seiner rede
verzichtete das findet hier immer so
einen gewissen ausgleich wenn einer
überzieht muss der andere redezeit
abgeben aus der fraktion wohlgemerkt
tino kubala der fdp fraktionschef
2022 zu verabschieden wir beraten in
dieser woche über eine neuverschuldung
in
schwindelerregender höhe von circa 139
milliarden euro damit wachsen die
geplanten ausgaben auf nahezu 500
milliarden euro ein herter herr
bundeskanzler
wann konnten sie als regierungschef
dieser ampel koalition eigentlich einen
arbeitstag mit dem gewissen beenden
unser land vorangebracht zu haben denn
eines muss ich sagen die verantwortung
für die desolate lage unseres landes
lastet zu recht schwer auf ihren
schultern
als ehemaliger bundesfinanzminister und
sozialdemokrat haben sie ihre
vorgängerinnen über jahrzehnte den boden
für eine realitätsferne wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik geben wir erleben hier und
heute den wirtschaftlich und sozialen
abstieg deutschlands und seiner bürger
und wie ist ihre reaktion darauf
entweder hört und sieht man den
bundeskanzler nicht oder man hört von
einem ehemaligen bundespräsidenten dass
man auch mal fiel in trieben frieren
können und genau das ist unwürdig meine
damen und herren unwürdig dem land
gegenüber führt dass sie als
bundesregierung verantwortung übernommen
haben und vor allem unwürdig den
menschen gegenüber die tagtäglich zur
wertschöpfung in deutschland und damit
zum wohl unserer gesellschaft beitragen
die cdu steht im übrigen nichts nach sie
haben ja selbst in der ard vom ende
unseres wohlstandes für eine gewisse
zeit gesprochen für mich hört sich das
so an als hätte die cdu deutschland
bereits aufgegeben und den glauben an
sich selbst verloren denn lösungen haben
die christdemokraten heute und auch sie
herr merz nicht hervorgebracht sie haben
kein wort zu den deutschen bürgern
gesagt kein wort zu den steuerzahlern in
diesem land meine damen und herren diese
beiden politiker bringen heute ihre
eigene ernte ein schauen sie sich in
unserem land um sie werden die
ergebnisse fehlgeleitete politik der
letzten jahrzehnte überall erkennt der
mann durch unser land wirkt diese träten
immer stärker in den vordergrund und
lassen sich auch nicht mehr vertuschen
beispielsweise wurde der spalt zwischen
den struktur stärken und den
strukturschwachen regionen sogar noch
vertieft und wir alle wissen für kaum
ein unternehmen des mittelstands ist es
wirtschaftlich überhaupt noch attraktiv
sich in einer strukturschwachen region
dauerhaft niederzulassen
hier hat der deutsche staat seit jahren
seine grund aufgabe nicht erfüllt und
die heißt aufbau und erhalt von
infrastruktur verkehrsnetze von straßen
und schiene breitbandausbau
gesundheitsversorgung und bildung sind
nur einige eckpfeiler
die einfach vorhanden sein müssen es ist
die aufgabe der regierungen in den
ländern und auch im bund die
grundlegenden voraussetzungen zu
schaffen damit gerade auch kleine und
mittelständische unternehmen und
insbesondere das handwerk existieren
können aber was ist eigentlich
was ist eigentlich ihre idee für
deutschland und den kontinent europa in
den nächsten 20 jahren werde die
bundesregierung wie werden wir nach der
sogenannten energiewende leben und
arbeiten wie geht es weiter dazu
schweigen sich komplett aus damit endet
die einseitige utopie der ampel
koalition meine damen und herren welche
industrien beispielsweise werden noch in
deutschland existieren und welche werden
wir entwickeln müssen womit werden die
menschen in diesem land ja geld
verdienen wer wird in diesem land
eigentlich überhaupt noch wertschöpfend
arbeiten zu diesen fragen hören wir
schon lange keine antworten mehr von
ihnen sie fahren mit ihrer politik nur
noch auf sicht und weiter was sollen wir
den nachfolgenden generationen was
würden sie ihren kindern eigentlich
raten welchen beruf sie erlernen welches
studium sie ergreifen sollen wir sehen
die berufsbilder der zukunft eigentlich
aus
investieren investieren sie überhaupt
noch einen gedanken in dieser wichtigen
frage stellung wir und viele deutsche
bürger jedenfalls können das aktuell
nicht erkennt ihre politik wehrt die
bundesregierung schafft deutschland und
europa als eigenständigen und
zukunftssicheren wirtschafts und
bildungsraum vollkommen ab
und nicht genug
nicht genug versuchen diese
bundesregierung seit jahren die
strukturellen probleme mit neuen
staatsschulden zu lesen natürlich auch
in diesem haushalt als alternative für
deutschland haben wir stets anständig
darauf hingewiesen dass sie unser land
damit in einer installation hinein
steuern und auch hier sollten wir recht
behalten meine damen und herren die
steigenden preise für die waren des
täglichen bedarfs und kraftstoffe haben
die bürger ihnen zu verdanken und sie
sollten sich wirklich schämen die
ergebnisse ihrer mangelhaften politik
mit dem deckmantel ukraine krieges
verhüllen zu holen sie alle hier wissen
sie alle hier wissen
dass die notenpresse der ezb seit jahren
auf hochtouren läuft um die missstände
zu verschleiern und genau das ist der
hauptgrund die geldmenge in europa
und dazu kommt noch jetzt das
beschlossene bemerkung auch das wird uns
hier in europa sprechen in den
erdölraffinerien von schwedt und lena
werden arbeitsplätze und in den regionen
dadurch die wirtschaftskraft verloren
geben ideologisch verblendet gehabt
diese bundesregierung seit monaten auf
ihren standpunkten und ebenso lange
machen wir sie ausdrückliche
einsparpotenziale aufmerksam sie jedoch
sind in einen ehrlichen kassensturz gar
überhaupt nicht interessiert einnahmen
ausgaben gegenüber stellen ist nicht
gewollt dabei werden es möglich dass sie
über 100 milliarden euro bei der energie
und klimafonds bei der auflösung der
jury klage oder einer ordentlichen außen
und entwicklungspolitik im deutschen
interesse einsparen könnten auch das
bürokratiemonster eu darf nicht weiter
unbedacht gefüttert werden würde man nur
einen teil dieser vorschläge in erwägung
ziehen könnten wir den staatshaushalt
entlasten und viel mehr wäre dieses geld
wurde immer frei ja auch für die
finanzierung der bundeswehr ohne neue
schulden aufzunehmen und ohne das
grundgesetz zu ändern oder um in die
chronisch unterfinanzierten sozialen
sicherungssysteme zu investieren das
sind sie nämlich den bürgern schuldig
die einen großteil ihrer einkommen jeden
monat dafür auf in und damit den
sozialstaat auch aufrecht
aber diese bundesregierung reagiert wie
gewohnt nachdenklich und könig zunächst
einmal ein entlastungspaket an das hört
sich natürlich auch immer toll und schön
an nicht nur das ist lange auf sich
warten lässt hat man sich zuallererst
einmal dem ideologischen klima baukasten
bedient und versucht mit einem neuen
euro ticket die bürger über die
sommermonate von ihren autos weg hin zum
psv zu bringen natürlich können wieder
nur diejenigen davon profitieren bei
denen noch busse und bahnen fahren
wieder werden nämlich die infrastruktur
schwachen regionen abgekoppelt und dann
kommt sie gerne vor hasselmann in meinen
wahlkreis nach görlitz das pferd pro
woche ein bus da können sie dann fahren
einmal für neun euro das ist der grund
die menschen dort haben rein gar nichts
von dieser kurzfristigen symbolpolitik
sie sind zur eigenen versorgung der mich
auf ihr auto angewiesen
und hiervon besonders betroffen sind
ausgerechnet die älteren und ältesten in
unserem land ausgerechnet diejenigen
denen wir unseren wohlstand zu verdanken
haben die in unser land aufgebaut haben
die werden zum dank für den regierungen
gedemütigt und auch vergessen aber
gerade diese menschen brauchen unsere
unterstützung verdient unsere
wertschätzung und auch entlastung haben
diese menschen verdienten ja die
preisspirale dreht sich immer noch
weiter hohe kraftstoffpreise werden
höhere lebensmittelpreise zur folge
haben die erzeugerpreise liegen schon
über den handelsreisen ergreifen sie
endlich pragmatische lösungen die bei
den bürgern und unternehmen auch
ankommen setzen sie die mehrwertsteuer
auf grundnahrungsmittel ausschaffen sie
entlastung bei der lohn und
einkommensteuer durch anhebung der
grundfreibeträge und noch einmal die co2
abgabe gehört abgeschafft
und auch wir selbst hier im deutschen
bundestag müssen endlich die
wahlrechtsreform vorantreiben hätte
dieses parlament die angemessene zahl
von 598 abgeordneten anstelle der 736
würden wir pro jahr 100 millionen euro
einsparen das würde zum vertrauen der
bürger in unsere parlamentarische arbeit
und in die politik beitragen und könnte
sich vielleicht sogar positiv auf die
wahlbeteiligung auswirken wahrscheinlich
wollen sie das aber gar nicht nette
kollegen ein weiter so kam es zum
schluss kommen letzter satz von
präsident denn wer die kollegen ein
weiter so kann und darf es nicht mehr
geben wir brauchen eine politik in der
unsere bürger ebenso zuerst bedacht
werden wie deutschland vielen dank
der bundestag debattiert über den
kanzler der
die generaldebatte ist das und zu diesem
kanzleretat gehört auch der bereich
kultur und medien und die zuständige
staatsministerin im kanzleramt claudia
roth hat jetzt als nächste das wort
krieg ist ein zustand bei welchem die
niedrigsten und lasterhaften menschen
macht und ruhm erlangen das sagte lew
tolstoi in diesen düsteren zeiten leben
wir und so ringen wir um die richtigen
antworten unsere koalition das parlament
genauso wie die menschen in unserem land
wir alle ringen um richtige antworten
denn genau das zeichnet doch eine
demokratische politik aus wir stellen
uns den aufgaben offen mit all unseren
zweifeln und mit den notwendigen
diskussionen denn es gibt sie nicht die
einfachen antworten
in diesen zeiten haben wir den
absolutheitsanspruch des krieges etwas
entgegenzusetzen
die demokratische meinungsbildung und
unser unterscheidungsvermögen das ist
auch aufgabe der kultur und
medienpolitik
ich werde mich in zwei wochen mit den
medien minister/innen der g7 treffen und
wir wollen uns zu drei ganz zentralen
punkten verständigen was können wir tun
um für das gesellschaftsmodell der
demokratie zu werben was können wir tun
und propaganda und desinformation
entgegenzutreten
und was können wir tun um diejenigen zu
schützen die dem demokratischen streit
und der freien meinungsbildung
verpflichtet sind und genau deswegen aus
ihren herkunftsländern und besonders aus
russland fliehen müssen journalistin den
sind fachkräfte der demokratie deswegen
haben wir zusammen mit dem ein programm
zu ihrem schutz aufgenommen und kämpfen
mit anderen ressorts gegen
desinformation was wir nicht brauchen
sind kultur boykotte und die
kulturalisierung von konflikten es ist
putins krieg und nicht puschkins krieg
die freiheit von kunst und kultur zu
verteilen das ist grundlegende aufgabe
von kulturpolitik und das sage ich auch
und gerade mit blick auf aktuelle
debatten liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lassen sie mich vier beispiele benennen
wie wir den kulturellen zusammenhalt in
unserem land stärken erstens wir kümmern
uns um die künstlerinnen und künstler
erst vorgestern habe ich gemeinsam mit
hubertus heil ich mit kulturschaffenden
ausgetauscht es geht jetzt um einen
konkreten arbeitsprozess um ihre soziale
lage zu verbessern von der
künstlersozialkasse über formen der
selbstständigen beschäftigung von
mindesten dem gender pay gap bis zur
altersvorsorge
es ist wichtig dass das zukunftsprogramm
neustadt bis mitte nächsten jahres
fortgesetzt werden kann wichtig mit
blick auf die weiteren anhaltenden
risiken und folgen der korona krise mit
denen die kulturszene ja nach wie vor zu
kämpfen hat zweitens wir wollen eine
breite in die zukunft gerichtete
erinnerungspolitik die erinnert an die
verbrechen des nationalsozialismus die
erinnert an das sed-unrecht die erinnert
an den kolonialismus und mit der
rückgabe von benin großen richtige
zeichen setzen wird eine erinnerungs
politik aber auch in
und für die einwanderungsgesellschaft
rechtsextremismus antisemitismus
rassismus sie zeigen doch ihre hässliche
fratze von melun bis solingen von halle
von ali bis hanau eine lebendige
erinnerungspolitik muss und wird darauf
antworten geben müssen und diese
erinnerungspolitik wird europäisch sein
deswegen habe ich meine erste
auslandsreise nach frankreich
unternommen und sie muss ein deutliches
zeichen gegen den antisemitismus und
führen unsere freundschaft mit israel
setzen und deswegen war ich auf meiner
zweiten reise in der vergangenen woche
in israel und habe mit dem israelischen
kulturminister eine verstärkte
zusammenarbeit verabredet drittens wir
wollen die vielfalt von kunst und kultur
und medien in unserem land fördern es
geht um den erhalt der kinos vor allem
im ländlichen raum um einen preis für
plattenläden und bibliotheken und museen
als dritte orte um wichtige
institutionen der musikalischen bildung
es geht um den film festival verband
scope um den bundes musikverband chor
und orchester um das jugendballett und
um so viel mehr nicht zuletzt geht es
darum die vielen einrichtungen und
bauten in ihren wahlkreisen zusatz zu
erhalten und zu sanieren und sie instand
zu halten
wirken
das alles wird nur gelingen wenn wir
nachhaltigkeit als voraussetzung von
freiheit verstehen ohne nachhaltigkeit
werden zukünftige generationen keine
freiheiten mehr haben das ist also
unsere verantwortung auch in der kultur
und medienpolitik und mit dem green
cards können wir einen entscheidenden
beitrag gegen die dramatische klimakrise
leisten wir wollen kunst und kultur mit
allen und für alle ermöglichen indem wir
ihre vielfalt und ihre freiheit sichern
und verteidigen all dies ist möglich
dank ihrer unterstützung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zum einen durch
die fachpolitiker innen ich nenne
stellvertretend für alle die vorsitzende
des kulturausschusses katrin boote und
zum anderen heute ganz besonders die
haushaltspolitiker namentlich otto
fricke dennis rohde andreas auftritt
aber eben auch kerstin radomski und
gesine lötzsch wir leben in düsteren
zeiten
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen wir
müssen lösungen erarbeiten wir müssen
handeln und lassen sie uns deshalb kunst
kultur und medien in freiheit in
gerechtigkeit und nachhaltigkeit
erfüllen vielen dank
claudia roth ganz begeistert und warum
ganz einfach der kultur etat wird um
sieben prozent erhöht auf
2,29 milliarden euro neben verschiedenen
dingen gibt es unter anderem auch geld
für projekte die zur erinnerung an
anschläge der jüngsten zeitgeschichte in
deutschland stärker ausgebaut werden
sollen hierfür sind 1,7 millionen euro
vorgesehen otto fricke der haushälter
deftigen was mit dem vertrauen innerhalb
dieser koalition zu tun hat und das ist
die tatsache dass wir gar nicht mehr
darüber reden dass wir die frage der alt
kanzler in einer sehr eleganten wie ich
finde und das möchte ich noch mal sagen
zu meinen sprecher kollegen kindler und
rode in einer sehr eleganten weise
gelöst haben dieser haushalts aus diese
koalition ist im haushaltsausschuss in
der lage komplizierte probleme zu lösen
und ich danke dafür dass wir das
geschafft haben was viele ja gedacht
haben was uns nicht gelingen würde
meinen dank möchte ich habe dann
meinen möchte ich aber auch dann an den
kollegen haase richten die da oben beim
kollegen märz sitzt der sich jetzt
bayern also sicherlich entschuldigt
dafür dass er ihn nicht erwähnt hat bei
der frage wie wir beim sondervermögen zu
lösungen kommen auch das möchte ich dann
sagen das ist haushaltsarbeit an der
stelle dafür zu sorgen dass man so etwas
hinbekommt und kollege haase ohne ihre
arbeit an der stelle wäre das nicht
gelungen dass wir heute nachmittag heute
abend so hoffe ich ein vernünftiges
ergebnis finden werde und herren
ich hätte mich auch gerne bei der linken
bedankt wenn sie da konstruktiv
mitgearbeitet hinter ja meine damen und
herren meine damen und herren ich will
das ausdrücklich noch mal sagen auch
weil ja jetzt noch ein großteil des
kabinetts anwesend ist die frage wie wir
mit dem haushalt gegenüber der regierung
umgehen hat auch etwas mit der frage zu
tun wie ein selbstbewusstes parlament
der regierung sagt was es von der
regierung erwartet und wo es
notwendigkeiten der veränderung sieht
das hat etwas zu tun mit der frage wie
geht man mit kw vermerken um das hat was
mit der frage mit von selbst
wirtschaften zu tun was sich alles sehr
sehr technisch an wird aber es ist liebe
regierung die frage der bindung an den
parlaments bin und da bitte ich auch in
den nächsten jahren sehr genau darauf zu
achten denn im haushaltsausschuss in
verbindung mit den fachausschüssen
werden dinge erarbeitet die manchmal
eben doch viel näher am menschen am
bürger an der bürgerinnen dran sind als
das was ein ministerialbeamter in
sicherlich guter fachlichkeit denkt und
deswegen hören sie öfters aufs parlament
gerade beim haushalt kann das von
vorteil sein meine damen und herren zum
kultur will ich nur eine sache noch in
gänze war claudia roth hat ja in einer
großen linie all die dinge gesagt die
sie wollte die wir wollten die
beschlossen worden ist und ich möchte
eine sache für den bereich kultur
hervorheben die sich eigentlich im
einzelplan des kollegen halbe findet
nämlich im einzelplan 11 die
künstlersozialkasse ich bin als
liberaler sehr glücklich darüber dass es
uns gelungen ist für die künstler an der
stelle eine größeres maß an sicherheit
schaffen wo sie in den letzten jahren
ganz besonders betroffen waren nämlich
bei der frage ihrer altersvorsorge hier
danke ich allen beteiligten dass sie ich
sag das mal so wünschen und anregungen
die auch ein wenig aus der reihe den
reihen der fdp kamen nach gegangen sind
und wir eine lösung finden die wir ja
dann noch gesetzlich ergänzen so sollte
politik in der ampel funktionieren weil
sie auch dafür sorgt dass kultur nicht
nur funktioniert sondern
kulturschaffender auch soziale
absicherung haben das ist ampel meine
damen und herren ich muss aber dann
ich muss aber ganz am schluss doch noch
mal zu cdu csu kommen herr frei der ist
glaube ich jetzt schon nicht mehr daher
frei hat eben gesagt ja warum
kritisieren sie uns na ja ich muss
einfach sagen eine solche opposition in
haushaltsverhandlungen habe ich noch nie
erlebt ich muss da einfach mal nur dinge
durch sie sagen an der stelle
kürzungsanträge für die
öffentlichkeitsarbeit der bundesligen
die diese koalition stellen wir kürzen
öffentlichkeitsarbeit unserer regierung
sagen es ist zu viel sagt die cdu die
regierung braucht mehr geld bei der
frage
300.000 euro für ein konzept
wirkungsorientierte haushaltsführung
sagte sagt die cdu csu das braucht man
nicht wirkungsorientierte
haushaltsführung ist für uns nicht
wichtig bei der frage
künstlersozialkasse die ich gerade
erwähnt habe stimmt die cdu dagegen und
jetzt das neueste projekt der
haushaltspolitik der märz soli also man
wundert sich dann an der stelle schon
welche art von oppositionspolitiker
button dann muss man eben liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der cdu csu
dann doch damit rechnen dass das nicht
funktioniert und dass sie dann auch
angegangen werden inhaltlich hier und
ein letztes
warum gelingt ihnen denn eigentlich
keine richtige kritik und
oppositionspolitik und das habe ich
gestern wieder beobachten können es ist
doch ganz einfach so bei ihm wenn man
mit den haushältern redet hört man
folgenden satz na ja unsere
fachpolitiker die wollen ja alle viel
viel mehr geld ausgeben und die lassen
wir auch einfach und ihr problem ist um
es mit matthäus 537 zu sagen statt
shakespeare kollege wurde ihre rede ist
nicht ja ja ihre rede ist auch nicht
nein nein sondern was sie machen ist sie
wollen auf der einen seite stetig mehr
ausgaben haben können auf der anderen
seite aber überhaupt nicht darstellen
wie sie diese finanzieren wollen und die
krönung das muss ich auch sagen war dann
für mich und damit möchte ich dann auch
schließen die krönung war für mich die
drucksache 14 10 wo ja märz sie immer
sagen das wäre ja alles gar nicht so mit
diesen 60 milliarden die sie als
angeblich verfassungswidrig das heißt
hier unter einem antrag der cdu csu
einnahmen für den haus ein achtung
einnahmen aus der rücklage und dann
schreiben sie
rückabwicklung des vorgehens beim
zweiten nachtragshaushalt 20 21 in höhe
von 60 milliarden ja das heißt sie
nehmen etwas von dem sie sagen herr merz
es sei verfassungswidrig es sei richtig
dass übrigens überhaupt noch nicht
aktiviert ist das noch überhaupt nicht
ausgegeben muss dieses geld nimmt die
cdu csu um ihre wünsche und ihre träume
davon wie man mehr geld ausgeben kann zu
nutzen das ist keine oppositionspolitik
sondern das ist etwas wo der rest besser
schweigen ist herzlichen dank
otto fricke der haushälter der fdp hat
es schöner mann angesprochen zum anfang
seiner rede die verhandlungen über das
sondervermögen gehen heute abend in den
ausschüssen weiter die union hatte da
offensichtlich bei der verwendung der
mittel noch nachfragen damit ist immer
noch nicht ganz geklärt ob es zur
abstimmung kommen wird am freitag wie
das jahr sprich geplant war aber
alle gehen hier im hohen hause davon aus
dass dann auch der wirtschaftsplan so
aufgestellt und erklärt wurde dass die
union dieser zweidrittelmehrheit diese
zweidrittelmehrheit bei der umstellung
des 100 milliarden sondervermögens im
grundgesetz mittragen wird jedenfalls
heute abend also die ausschusssitzungen
dazu vielleicht sagt ja ulrich lange von
der union der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende auch etwas zu
diesem thema
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich würde mit etwas bedienen was mich
seit einigen wochen und monaten doch ein
bisschen verwundert liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen insbesondere der spd lieber
kollege post sie haben etwas vorher als
unterkomplex bezeichnet die ich
bezeichne ist als unterkomplex wenn eine
fraktion
von 24 jahren 20 jahre regiert oder
mitregiert hat und dann ein
bundeskanzler sich hinstellt und mit dem
finger auf andere zeigt herr
bundeskanzler
das ist unter dem niveau eines kanzlers
dieses landes der auch zur politik der
vergangenheit die er mit gestaltet hat
stehen sollte warum sage ich dass wenn
es um die verteidigungsminister geht
erinnere ich doch mal anfing und struck
wenn es um die finanzminister geht
erinnere ich an lafontaine eickel
steinbrück und scholz und wenn es um
sozialminister geht an alles holz
müntefering mit clement riester und so
weiter liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben zusammen regiert sie haben mit
den grünen hier haben wir mit der fdp
regiert haben wir die wehrpflicht
übrigens abgeschafft jeder hat hier
verantwortung für dieses land und hat
diese verantwortung entsprechend
getragen
was uns allerdings jetzt belastet aus
den letzten sechs monaten dieser neuen
regierung ist eine gigantische
neuverschuldung wie sie die
bundesrepublik deutschland nicht gekannt
hat bisher und dann nützen die
rechentricks nicht lieber kollege
lindner 140 milliarden neuverschuldung
60 milliarden zweiter nachtragshaushalt
und ein sondervermögen heißt zwar
sondervermögen man nennt es auch bei
feminismus letztlich sind es schulden
mit denen das hier finanziert wird unter
dem strich 300 milliarden 300 milliarden
schulden das ist mehr als adenauer
erhard kiesinger brandt mit und kohl bis
1990 zusammen gemacht haben unsolide und
solidarisch unverantwortlich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
[Applaus]
niemand
niemand bestreitet dass
mit corona und dem russischen überfall
auf die ukraine wer eine ganz besondere
situation haben aber zum glück hat die
union zeit
hart gearbeitet für diese schwarze null
und ein fundament geschaffen dass
überhaupt in der lage sind das zu
leisten was wir uns jetzt geleistet
haben in den letzten monaten
lebe
lieber kollege lindner ich habe
vorgestern im interview im heute schon
mal gesehen und das war schon wirklich
beachtlich da reden sie zum einen dass
die schuldenbremse eingehalten werden
muss
reden auf der anderen seite dann
dass man sich an schulden machen gewöhnt
habe da meinen sie wohl ihre beiden
koalitionspartnern und gleichzeitig
erklären sie zur schuldenbremse 20 23
zurückkehren zu wollen
gleichzeitig verkündet der
sozialminister ein klima geld und wir
haben wir es vorhin beim beifall beim
thema klima geld gesehen tosende applaus
ein bisschen applaus kein applaus sowas
nenne ich zerfalls koalition liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
solide solide haushaltspolitik
solide haushaltspolitik ist ein
fundament für
generationengerechtigkeit
denn andere die generationen nach uns
müssen sonst das ausbügeln was wir jetzt
machen und ersatz hat einfach richtig
keit auf schuldenbergen können kinder
nicht spielen und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen in der jetzigen phase der
aktuellen inflation wird das ganze noch
viel brandgefährlicher und das wissen
sie wir hatten schon mal in diesem land
eine stagnation
koalition
in den 70er jahren
auch daran möchte ich erinnern denn wer
darunter zu leiden hat sind die
mittleren und kleineren einkommen das
sind die rentnerinnen und rentner
und genau an dieser stelle stehen wir
und deswegen brauchen wir solidität
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die einhaltung der schuldenbremse lieber
finanzminister darin werden wir sie
messen denn man hat manchmal das gefühl
sie wären in dieser koalition gerne der
neue ludwig erhard geworden tatsächlich
drohen sie zum neuen hans eichel zu
werden und das ganze würde ich dann auch
entsprechend im nächsten jahr wieder
kommentieren wollen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
wir hatten vorhin von die
widersprüchlichkeit einerseits offene
märkte andererseits kein
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada
einerseits brauchen wir gas andererseits
sollen die stadtwerke die gasnetze
zurückbauen wir haben lieber
landwirtschaftsminister auch eine
widersprüchlichkeit wir geben ihnen
recht
regionale erzeugnisse sind positiv der
wochenmarkt ist etwas positives
all das ist richtig aber trotzdem droht
der welt in manchen teilen eine
hungerkatastrophe
und deutschland rettet sicherlich nicht
allein davor aber jeder hektar fläche
der angebaut wird für die
lebensmittelversorgung ist in einer
solchen situation ein gewonnener und wir
haben keinen misstrauen gegen unsere
bauern und gegen und über unseren
landwirten wir haben vertrauen und sagen
danke für die nahrungsmittelsicherheit
die wir hier bei uns haben
zeitenwende ein schlagwort das seit ein
paar wochen
die diskussion prägt und inzwischen ja
selbst bei wikipedia zu finden ist aber
außer dem boot haben wir eher das gefühl
einer ruhigen hand vor allem dann wenn
es um die waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine und die ruhige hand lieber
bundeskanzler die scheinen sie sich von
ihrem letzten spd-vorgänger abgeschaut
zu haben der in einem ganz besonderen
verhältnis ja auch zu russland
verhältnis ja auch zu russland unsere
verbündeten setzen auf uns das sagen sie
uns jeden tag wenn wir dann allerdings
lesen was der polnische staatspräsident
tue da sagt oder der britische
aussenminister landsbergis dann sehen
wir das genau das hier nicht zutrifft
diese geschlossenheit die wir brauchen
diese waffenlieferungen die die ukraine
von uns zu recht erwarten kann liefern
sie nicht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe gott liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
niemand kann sich aussuchen in was für
zeiten er oder sie lebt niemand kann
sich aussuchen wie man in einer solchen
situation vorab umgeht aber
zeitenwende bedeutet besondere
verantwortung
zeitenwende bedeutet für uns dass wir
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern und konstruktiv die politische
ordnung in europa neu gestalten und den
vielfältigen krisen und
herausforderungen
stellen
nicht gegeneinander
das haben wir als union in den letzten
wochen auch als opposition deutlich
unter beweis gestellt aber auch nicht
ideologie getrieben sondern mit klarem
verantwortungsbewusstsein liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen unsere
fraktionsvorsitz hat heute drei fragen
gestellt an sie herr bundeskanzler
die bevölkerung hat einen anspruch auf
antworten wir werden sie an diesen
antworten hier messen dankeschön
ulrich lange war das meine damen und
herren die nächste rednerin kommt aus
dem kanzleramt nämlich die
staatsministerin für migration
flüchtlinge und integration
aller bali radovan von der spd
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der haushalt und die politik
der koalition sprechen eine klare
sprache
wir wollen mehr fortschritt und respekt
mehr sicherheit um zusammenhalt für alle
ob mit oder ohne einwanderungsgeschichte
ob geflüchtet oder her gekommen zum
arbeiten oder studieren 16 verschlafene
jahre
integrationspolitik holen wir jetzt nach
mit einer klaren agenda die teilhabe von
anfang an
für ein modernes einwanderungsland für
knallharte kante gegen rassismus das ist
der neuanfang in der integrationspolitik
dazu zwei beispiele hinterlegt in meinem
haushalt erster belegen im kampf gegen
rassismus endlich richtig nach die
straftaten sind gezählt die probleme
bekannt erst gerade vom national
diskriminierung und rassismus monitor
benannt 90 prozent der repräsentativ
befragten sagen ja es gibt rassismus in
deutschland aber die große mehrheit will
rassismus entgegentreten mit widerspruch
im alltag mit demonstration mit
ehrenamtlicher arbeit als anti rassismus
beauftragte der bundesregierung werde
ich diese aufgabe erstmals mit einem
haushaltstitel in höhe von acht
millionen euro angehen dafür danke ich
besonders den kolleginnen und kollegen
des haushaltsausschusses wir brauchen
beste hilfe vor ort von polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden aber auch und
unabhängigen beratungsstellen da ist
noch viel luft nach oben auch
strukturell darum will ich die
bestehenden beratungsstrukturen vor ort
stärken und dafür sorgen dass ihre
arbeit deutschlandweit bekannte und
erreichbar ist das ist wichtig denn die
opfer beraten stellen helfen allen
individuell und persönlich die rassismus
erleben gemeinsam mit der
zivilgesellschaft mit den
migrantenorganisationen mit der
wissenschaft mit den ländern und
kommunen mit verbänden wählten wir
schauen wo die lücken noch offen sind
und wir werden diese schließen wir
dürfen die betroffenen von rassismus nie
wieder alleine lassen
die erinnerung darf nicht verlassen das
schulden wir den hinterbliebenen der nsu
wurde den anschlägen vom könig des von
solingen münchen halle hanau den
angehörigen von marwa el sherbini den
menschen die vor 30 jahren in rostock
lichtenhagen um ihr leben gefürchtet
haben sie sind unvergessen und
alleine
und alleine diese aufzählung und das was
wir heute wieder aus der ganz rechten
ecke des saals gehört haben zeigt wir
haben ein problem und das werden wir
jetzt angehen
weiter wir brauchen integration ab tag
eins für alle die hier leben zur
eingewanderten und gefürchtete auch für
800.000 menschen die gerade aus der
ukraine zions geflohen sind wir täten
gut daran viele der positiven
erfahrungen die wir gerade machen auch
für andere menschen zu nutzen dass das
chancen aufenthaltsrecht wird dafür eine
gute gelegenheit sein für eine gute
aufnahme aus der ukraine sorgen in
diesen wochen auch die vielen
ehrenamtlichen in den kommunen vor ort
sie verdienen unseren großen respekt und
dann aber es darf nicht bei worten
bleiben deshalb unterstütze ich die
ehrenamtliche koordination mit unter
anderem 20 millionen euro in meinem
haushalt wir lassen die ehrenamtlichen
nicht alleine
noch in aller klarheit jedes jahr in dem
wir für integration und anti rassismus
arbeit im bundeshaushalt investieren
zahlt sich doppelt und dreifach aus das
ist eine investition für unseren
zusammenhalt für ein friedliches
miteinander für unsere demokratie vielen
dank
soweit die beauftragte der
bundesregierung für migration
flüchtlinge und integration gut drei
millionen euro möchte die
bundesregierung
mehr für flüchtlings projekte ausgeben
nächster redner ist martin erwin rinner
auf die fraktion das präsidium
kunst und kultur bedürfen zwingend der
freiheit ist diese freiheit nicht
vorhanden dann wird kunst und kultur
ganz schnell zur vorgegebenen
auftragsarbeit artikel 5 unseres
grundgesetzes garantiert die freiheit
von kunst und kultur aber das wissen sie
ja alle hier im hohen hause sind ja
alles experten im politik demokratie und
recht ganz unverhohlen werden kunst
kultur und medien im us-haushalt der
sommertour begeisterten frau roth immer
massiver auf modernen bau kiss muss
getrennt und immer schön das control
mainstreaming das diversity management
und den chandler dadaismus betonen
doch hat das noch viel mit unserer
deutschen kultur und seine förderung zu
tun mein wieder nach wenn man schon
immer gerne in der transparenten
hinterherlief auf denen steht nie wieder
deutschland oder wenn man einen
ampelmann zum kollegen hat der noch nie
etwas mit deutschland anzufangen wusste
und es bis heute nicht weiß oder wenn
man eine kollegin in der abend bedeute
gemeinschaft hat die eine spezifisch
deutsche kultur jenseits der sprache
schlicht nicht identifizieren können
ausgebeutete steuerzahler hat die
einigen kultureller und künstlerischer
freiheit zu alimentieren und das video
logi gedrängten politik und den
parametern die geschlechtergerechtigkeit
diversität entwicklung
multikulturalismus klimaneutralität
vorgegeben innerhalb der kultur der
kunst medien und natürlich auch wo
gegeben der allgegenwärtige kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus rassismus der vom
kulturmarxismus
angeblasen und aufgeblasene um geistige
popanz unserer zeit was früher das
durchaus strittige kunstprojekt war ist
heute der klimabeauftragte
der die planung und die durchführung
eines kunstprojektes zu überwachen hat
oder die anlaufstelle greencard für die
beratung von kultureinrichtungen zu
fragen der ökologischen transformation
naja
wer dagegen aufbegehrt der ist nicht
länger nur ein ordner kulturbanausen ein
er ist auch ein nicht zu tolerierende
rechter denen es mit allen mitteln zu
bekämpfen gilt sie und ihre politiker
nicht nur im bereich der kultur und in
den medien sondern überall
unüberwindbare ideologie membranen
installiert diese membranen sondern
demokratische freiheit vorgabe doch
diese membranen sind nur mit einem
zeitleisten kultur marxistischen ungeist
durchlässig und wer die trecker themen
ihrer öko sozialistischen klub al islam
politik unterstützt foto dröge werden
durch das füllhorn des steuerzahlers
brasilianer sehnt gefüllt auf diese
weise passt ist und wegen ihrer absolut
moralische ampel aber jung weiter an
einer neuen gesellschaft die die
mehrheit der bürger gar nicht haben will
und sie dass die läuft also deutlich
erkennen dass dieser andersdenkenden
teil unserer gesellschaft für sie gar
keinen wert mehr hat ich rate ihnen
umkehr also meter neuer ist dringend
notwendig dankeschön
der abgeordnete am ende
ich mache sie darauf aufmerksam dass wir
hier eine verabredung und regelung haben
dass die amtierenden präsidenten bzw
präsidentinnen auch in dieser weise
gewürdigt werden da geht es nicht um die
person sondern tatsächlich um die würde
des gesamten parlamentes insofern habe
ich jetzt darauf verzichtet ihre rede zu
unterbrechen und die anrede welche nicht
korrekt zu rügen weiß auch auf hin das
sollte es sich im laufe des tages noch
einmal ereignen sicherlich die dann
amtierenden präsidentinnen und
präsidenten ob die entsprechenden
maßnahmen
bundestags-vizepräsidentin petra pau hat
hier noch mal darauf verwiesen
normalerweise sprechen hier die
rednerinnen und redner auch immer die
bundestagspräsidentin oder die
entsprechenden vizepräsident hinein an
nächster redner ist nun andreas dresch
für bündnis 90 die grünen im bundestag
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren während wir hier sprechen
sterben in der ukraine menschen und
werden von einem autoritären einem
rechtsextremen diktator mit größter
brutalität in die flucht geschlagen
viele von denen viele hunderttausend von
ihnen kommen zu uns hier nach
deutschland und wir haben da eine
riesige aufgabe und es ist richtig dass
wir uns dieser aufgabe annehmen und vor
allem vor dem hintergrund dessen was in
den letzten wochen in den rechtsextremen
netzwerken zu dieser frage unterwegs war
ist es mir ein anliegen mit größter
überzeugung zu sagen es ist richtig dass
wir diesen menschen die sozialsysteme
öffnen ist es richtig dass wir diesen
menschen unseren arbeitsmarkt öffnen
beratungen geben und es ist darüber
hinaus richtig dass wir im etat von maly
radio waren drei millionen euro extra
einstellen und projekte und programme
voranzutreiben die an der stelle helfen
das gut investiertes geld
und ich möchte
ergänzen ganz explizit den großen dank
an christian dürr dass er das gerade so
deutlich gemacht hat wir werden den
historischen fehler der union den der
über jahrzehnte hier in deutschland ein
problem man nicht machen wir werden den
menschen in zukunft geben und sie werden
teil dieser gesellschaft und wir werden
alle davon profitieren
der krieg in der ukraine ist auch ein
krieg gegen die freiheit des denkens
gegen journalistin journalisten gegen
die liberale demokratie die uns so
wichtig ist claudia roth hat es gesagt
wir werden dieses thema auch zum g7
thema machen weil es auf diese ebene
gehört aber wir warten nicht darauf wir
machen jetzt exil programme für
geflüchtete für kultur und medien
schaffende die von hier aus triebs
kriegstreibern sagen dass wir weiterhin
für demokratie für freiheit auf der welt
eintreten wir stärken die deutsche welle
mit über 13 millionen euro um freie
medien freies denken in diese welt zu
tragen und das ist die botschaft auch
aus der kulturpolitik hier in
deutschland wir werden für die liberale
demokratie streiten in deutschland und
weltweit
ein zweiter punkt ist mir wichtig mit
dem krieg in der ukraine gehen auch
soziale härten für kulturschaffende
einher und der kollege fricke hat es
genannt und an der stelle das ist schon
das zweite lob für einen kollegen aus
der fdp mache ich gerne der kollege
fricke hat es genannt wir haben bei der
künstlersozialkasse
richtig was drauf gelegt 85 58 millionen
euro die wir an der stelle
zusammengekriegt haben um dafür zu
sorgen dass in den nächsten jahren oder
im nächsten jahr der beitragssatz nicht
durch die decke schießt an der stelle
bin da gerne darauf eingegangen ich habe
das mit freuden unterstützt aber die
initiative kam von kollege fricke und
auch das muss man hier im einmal
anerkennen
die klimakrise ist ein weiteres riesiges
thema das wir in den sälen und auf den
bühnen überall in deutschland längst
haben green card ist die ganz konkrete
antwort auch aus der kulturbranche
heraus dass es das was von dort kommt
wenn man da unterwegs ist dann ist das
dort ein riesenthema die
kulturschaffenden stehen in den
startlöchern sie wollen das thema
angehen und das was wir tun ist das
signal von seiten der bundesregierung zu
setzen ja das ist richtig wir
unterstützen das mit dem green card test
und 5 millionen euro im etat der kultur
staatsministerin
ein weiteres thema ist mir wichtig der
umgang mit der aufarbeitung unseres
kolonialen erbes und das entwickeln
einer neuen erinnerungskultur und meine
kolleginnen arbeits test bei jesus hat
es hier in der letzten debatte so
plastisch gesagt und ich möchte das
wiederholen zitat stellen sie sich vor
dass große teile unseres kulturgutes
nicht in unseren museen liegt sondern
auf einem anderen kontinent werke von
schiller goethe kant lägen nicht in
unsere bibliotheken und sehr vor um sie
zu erforschen müssen sie in ein anderes
land reisen wo für sie ein visum
brauchen was ihnen in der regel nicht
gewährt wird was würde das mit unserer
gesellschaft machen zitat ende wir haben
hier eine zutiefst ernste verantwortung
die wir angehen müssen und es bestürzt
mich die bei union dass sie sich dieser
verantwortung
weiterhin explizit verweigern in den
verhandlungen hier im bundestag haben
sie den antrag gestellt fast das
komplette geld was wir dafür eingestellt
haben zu streichen wer das nicht glaubt
es ist schwarz und weiß in den
protokollen ich kann sie nur auffordern
kommen sie im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert angaben wir als ampel
politik machen wir haben 65 millionen
euro im etat eingestellt wir gehen das
thema an und für unvertretbar der umgang
mit der vergangenheit und das entwickeln
einer neuen erinnerungskultur an der
stelle erst begonnen
für aufsehen hat gesorgt und deswegen
möchte ich an der stelle das noch einmal
erwähnen dass wir sechs millionen euro
für die stiftung preußischer
kulturbesitz gesperrt haben und ich
möchte ihnen sagen warum nicht weil es
uns an wertschätzung für den großen
kulturschatz mangelt den es dort ohne
zweifel gibt im gegenteil wir schätzen
dass der wert aber die stiftung braucht
reformen und deswegen haben wir gesagt
wir sperren das geld und das wird erst
weiteres geld vom bund geben wenn diese
reformen auch umgesetzt werden die ampel
steht für eine progressive kulturpolitik
das machen wir mit diesem etat deutlich
und ich freue mich auf die weitere
zusammenarbeit zu dem thema in den
nächsten jahren dankeschön
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen war dass
andreas auth rich
und nächste rednerin ist ein nicole
merten für die fdp-fraktion die
kulturpolitische sprecherin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
kunst und kultur sind mehr als
unterhaltung sie sind spiegel unserer
gesellschaft und zugleich motor für die
auseinandersetzung mit der vergangenheit
und dagegen sie schaffen verdienen
öffnen räume für den austausch über alle
grenzen hinweg die korona krise hat in
den vergangenen jahren jedem einzelnen
bei uns vor augen geführt wie
einschneidend der verzicht auf das
kulturelle leben war und uns in der
agentes bestärkt die bedeutend fünft und
kultur ist kunst und kultur formen
gesellschaften zu gemeinschaften bauen
brücken für die menschen
unterschiedlichster herkunft und über
generationen hinweg kultur stiftet
orientierung und halt in zeiten
beispielloser globaler krisen brauchen
wir kunst und kultur als türöffner und
nur so
wieso werden denkanstöße transportiert
und diskutiert das ist die basis unseres
demokratischen fundament und das gilt es
mit ganzer kraft zu stärken und zu
verteilen
unser bekenntnis zur demokratie drückt
sich durch den spürbaren mittel aufwuchs
für kultur und medien in dieser
wirtschaftlich schwierigen zeit aus denn
gerade in zeiten von krieg und krise
gilt es sicherheiten zu schaffen und das
haben die liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
in diesem haushaltsjahr liegen wir bei
einer rekord summe von 22 9 milliarden
euro für kultur und medien das
entspricht einem wachstum das tournee
geht es um rund 7 prozent gegenüber dem
vorjahr
als kulturpolitische sprecher seiner
fraktion freue ich mich sehr dass wir
mit diesem haushaltsentwurf impulse
setzen können wir in unserem sinne
württemberg
wir investieren währenddessen ausbauen
vielfältige nachhaltigen kulturbetriebs
und in die verbesserung der sozialen
lage zur stärkung von künstlerinnen und
künstlern durch die speicherung der
einzusetzenden mittel können die hilfen
für deutschlands kreative die pandemie
bedingt unter großen finanziellen
einbußen leiden weiterhin fortgesetzt
werden die kultur und kreativwirtschaft
ist ein integraler bestandteil der
deutschen wirtschaft und benötigt für
eine langfristige stabilität dringend
planungssicherheit
kunstwissenschaftlerin die einen
direkten einblick in die kultur und
kunstszene hat wünsche ich mir eins
daher ausdrücklich unser gemeinsames
ziel muss ganz klar laufen vorhang auf
und zwar für alle bereiche
ich möchte hier nicht mehr zahlen muss
auch wenn der wissel der
haushaltsentwurf wirklich dazu einlädt
aber ein paar beispiele möchte ich
zumindest gern hervorheben wir
investieren in stein und bein das
bedeutet wir investieren von mindesten
der bedeutet das bedeutet investitionen
von 66 millionen euro für kulturelle
bauten um notwendige sanierungsmaßnahmen
anzustoßen weitere zehn millionen euro
fließen in die erhaltung der
kinolandschaft
insbesondere und kinos im ländlichen
raum zu unterstützen und verstärken den
bundes music for four unter fester denn
besonders in dieser zeit können wir
festhalten singen überwindet grenzen
derzeit blicken wir aber wohl alle
fokussiert über unsere landesgrenzen
hinaus wir sind mit der brutalen
realität konfrontiert dass sich die welt
verändert und damit all unsere
lebensbereiche
kunst und kultur haben in zeiten von
umbrüchen schon immer eine besondere
unsere rolle eingenommen sie reflektiert
unsere gesellschaft bewertet kommentiert
und stellt sich den herausforderungen
nur eines wird kunst gewiss niemals zu
tun sie unterwirft sich nicht nichts und
niemandem sie ist transmitter und bleibt
uhr öffnen während die welt um sie herum
erschüttert und wir wollen und werden
nicht zusehen wie ein aggressor alles
daran setzt die kultur und identität
einer nation sukzessive auszulöschen
daher werden wir 22 millionen euro
zusätzlich in kulturen gegen hilfen für
die ukraine investieren und die
gravierenden auswirkungen des krieges
weiter abzufangen wir werden alles daran
setzen die ukrainischen kulturstätten
vor der russischen zerstörung zu
bewahren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben uns viel vorgenommen
es gibt viel zu tun und aber auch viel
zu bewerben vielen dank die
aufmerksamkeit
sagt
merten ist eben noch mal auch auf den
ukraine krieg eingegangen rund 5,9
millionen menschen sind nach
einer analyse des instituts der
deutschen wirtschaft auf der flucht das
stellt natürlich auch die regierung
hierzulande vor neue herausforderungen
auch wenn nicht ganz klar ist wie viele
davon in deutschland sind 610.000 von
ihnen sind in deutschland registriert
aber da sie ja sich nicht registrieren
müssen sondern eventuell auch
weiterfahren wollen ist diese zahl doch
recht unklar kerstin radomski spricht
jetzt für die unionsfraktion
die gerade in den aktuell bewegten
zeiten unsere verantwortung fördern und
insbesondere auch unsere verpflichtung
im sinne unseres kulturellen
deshalb erkennen wir als opposition wie
die regierungskoalition die bemühungen
ihrer vorgänger auch in der neuen
legislaturperiode fortzusetzen versucht
nachdem der kultur etat in der amtszeit
von staatsministerin monika grütters um
mehr als zwei drittel aufgewachsen ist
legen sie immerhin noch sieben prozent
drauf das entspricht nicht dem
steigerungs volumen der letzten acht
jahre
aber wir sehen ihr zeichen des guten
willens an dieser stelle
zugleich kritisieren wir dass sie so
wenig aus dem geld machen und hätten
doch deutlich mehr mut erwartet ihr
ansatz greencard schafft soll innovativ
klingen ist aber vor allen dingen
ideologie beladen
und wenn die frau roth fragen was man
für die pressefreiheit tun kann sie
befinden sich also zu sagen schon in den
haushaltsberatungen für den herbst als
bundesregierung mit dem
finanzministerium dann rate ich ihnen
noch etwas für den presserat zu tun die
parlamentarier haben das gemacht der
ampelkoalition und haben geld mehr geld
für den presserat zur verfügung gestellt
ich möchte aber heute projekte
hervorheben die konkrete vor allen
dingen näher bei den menschen wirken und
wie wir sie dabei unterstützen können
kulturelle dinge zu machen wir haben
gefordert dass ehrenamtliche chöre und
orchester vor ort unterstützt werden der
musik als amateur musik vor sollte von
uns aus mit zehn millionen euro
ausgestattet werden denn amateur musik
ist das fundament unseres kulturellen
lebens auch in ländlichen regionen
damit geben wir ein engagement von 4
zehn millionen freizeit und
laienmusikern in deutschland hervor und
treten zugleich für die gleichwertigkeit
der lebensverhältnisse sowie für die
stärkung des gemeinwesens 1 es ist für
uns gemeinsam ist interesse und
verpflichtung das engagement und die
arbeit der vielen zu unterstützen und
zukunftssicher zu machen auch im sinne
des immateriellen kulturerbes
wenn möglichst viel geld konkret bei
11.000 vereinen im ganzen land ankommt
dann landet es in der herzkammer der
musiklandschaft statt nur bei
spitzengremien oder dachorganisationen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auch das
zukunftsprogramm kino wurde von 10 um 10
millionen auf 25 millionen angehoben und
wir haben diese ampel antrag zugestimmt
denn es entspricht unseren forderungen
und deshalb ist erhöht das programm
wurde 2020 von der damaligen
staatsministerin monika grütters ins
leben rufen besonders kinos die in
strukturell oder kulturellen funktionen
an ihrem standort erfüllen wollen wir
stärken und wir alle sollten dafür
eintreten dass dieses zukunftsprogramm
auch weiterhin bestand hat
blicken wir auf das neue humboldt forum
in berlin im rahmen der einbringung des
etats habe ich dazu aufgerufen sich noch
stärker mit diesem jungen ort
auseinanderzusetzen
wir als zuständige unions abgeordnete
haben gestern dort diesen ort besucht
und ich weiß viele von uns waren auch
schon vorher einmal einzeln dort und wir
möchten dass sich das humboldt forum zu
einem ort entwickelt wo ganz im sinne
der aufklärung und weltoffenheit den
kulturen eine bühne geboten wird deshalb
haben wir natürlich der kürzung diese
des etats nicht zugestimmt die die ampel
koalition vorgenommen hat und auch der
schwere von sechs millionen des geldes
für die spk konnten wir nicht zustimmen
weil dass es dringend benötigtes geld
und ich habe es im ausschuss schon
gesagt eine sperre der politischen
gremien führt nicht zu einer reform für
die die politik an der stelle nicht
verantwortlich ist
zum schluss möchte ich ein punkt
ansprechen der bei dem selbst ernannten
progressiven leider häufig als
antiquiert und als auslaufmodell abgetan
wird das schicksal der vertriebenen und
ihr leben lang ihr lebenslanges trauma
es wurde heute fiel der begriff
erinnerungskultur bedient und es wurde
sogar von neuer erinnerungskultur
gesprochen ich finde es wichtig dass wir
auch nicht die teile unserer gemeinsamen
geschichte vergessen die unserer
erinnerungskultur entsprechen die ampel
hat gerade in zeiten in der millionen
menschen aus ihrer heimat fliehen und
voller ängste sind den menschen die
projekt fördermittel gekürzt für die die
deutschen heimatvertriebenen im grunde
genommen da stehen 1 millionen euro
wurden gekürzt wenn das ihre neue
erinnerungskultur ist oder das
umschichten von geld in neue
erinnerungskultur
politik dann finde ich das wirklich
schwierig dabei kommen gerade viele
ältere menschen inzwischen angesichts
der bilder die sie im fernsehen sehen
mit ihren ängsten nicht mehr klar es
kommen die ängste aus ihrer jugend und
kindheit hervor und das scheinbar
bewältigte bricht wieder auf ich finde
wir als parlamentarier müssen da
gemeinsam zusammenstehen und ich fordere
sie auch im nächsten haushalt entwurf
dieses geld wieder drauf zu legen denn
vertreibung findet nicht nur heute statt
vertreibung gab es in vielfältiger art
und weise und wir haben in diesem
bereich eine große verantwortung
[Applaus]
wir werden alle maßnahmen kritisch
begleiten ich möchte aber auch einen
kollegen des parlamentarischen bereich
für die guten beratung danken und hoffe
auf die nächsten haushaltsberatungen die
schon bald ansteht vielen dank
die kritik aus der unionsfraktion unter
anderem dass die
projekte zu ideologie gesteuert
andreas dresch mit einer
kurzintervention bündnis 90/die kommen
die eine anmerkung hätte ich und zwar zu
dem fakt dass sie gesagt haben sie waren
im humboldtforum und haben sich das
angeschaut auch ich war da und hab mir
das sehr genau angeschaut und an der
stelle vermisse ich erneut die
differenziertheit auch im umgang zum
beispiel mit unserer kolonialen
vergangenheit wenn man dort ist
und sich anschaut was dort passiert dann
gibt es einen teil die stiftung humboldt
forum die versucht da tatsächlich eine
weltoffene debatte zu etablieren wenn
man weiter geht da stehen dort wie
tränen wo ohne jegliche erklärungen
wissmann eroberungen des kongo steht und
eine eine jahreszahl dazu nichts über
die verbrechen nur ausstellung des
raubgutes was damals nach deutschland
gebracht wurde keine erklärung keine
auseinandersetzung das sind wir
betrieben der stiftung preußischer
kulturbesitz sie dort stehen wenn man
mit diesem humboldt-forum umgeht dann
kann man sagen dass da leute sind die
sich bemühen das kann man wertschätzen
eine weltoffene debatte zu etablieren
aber dann muss man sagen dass das ein
ort ist der mit unserer vergangenheit in
einer form umgeht der nicht adäquat ist
und genau diese debatte müssen wir
ernsthaft für und deswegen führen wir
die ernsthaft deswegen haben wir an der
stelle auch gesagt dass wir geld sparen
dass wir noch mal geld raus hin zum
druck zu erzeugen weil wir änderungen
brauchen und diese veränderungen werden
wir mit aller kraft angehen
wir haben das wort zur erwiderung
ja vielen duncan hat auch audritz für
ihre anmerkung ich glaube dass mit geld
sperren nicht dialog möglich wird ich
glaube dass es noch unterschiedliche
herangehensweise wenn sie bemängeln dass
die beschriftung im humboldt-forum nicht
ihren ansprüchen an dieser stelle
entsprechend ich konnte nicht alle
gestern tatsächlich lesen ich glaube man
braucht da viele tage für um sich jedes
detail anzuschauen aber dann glaube ich
muss man in den dialog gehen mit den
wissenschaftlern vor ort und auch mit
den ländern die da betroffen sind ob die
das genauso sehen und ich glaube da 5
millionen oder sechs millionen zu
sperren um dinge zu erpressen ist für
mich der falsche weg der politischen
auseinandersetzung aber jeder weg
gewählt da seinen eigenen weg und ich
denke wir kommen da sicherlich alle
gemeinsam zu einer guten lösung
so war die kurzintervention dann nochmal
zum thema raubkunst debatte ist seit
eröffnung des humboldt forums im
berliner stadtschloss doch sehr laut
wird hier auch immer noch weitergeführt
und jetzt auch auf finanzieller ebene
gibt es da spricht jetzt für die
spd-fraktion sie sitzt im
haushaltsausschuss dass diese regierung
handelt dass sie spürbar die menschen
entlastet dass sie die wirtschaft
stabilisiert und auch investitionen an
schiebt das in der ausstattung anspruch
haben der eben auch auf die zukunft
ausgerechnet ist und wir tun dies und
haben dies getan in den vergangenen zehn
wochen unter dunklen wolken die drei
große krisen darstellen die aktuellen
auswirkungen innen wie außenpolitisch
der ukraine des krieges die nachwirkung
der korona pandemie die noch nicht zu
ende ist und auch die klimakrise die wir
nicht vergessen dürfen mit den drohenden
viel größer werdenden zukünftigen
auswirkungen und wir haben diesen
haushalt aufgestellt so dass er trotz
der nahezu größten möglichen
unsicherheit jetzt mit dem was wir
beschließen werden die größtmögliche ein
maximum an sicherheit bietet ein
sicherheit für die menschen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz wird es zu
beginn dieser debatte sehr deutlich
gesagt weil wir die sorgen der menschen
in den blick nehmen und unsere politik
daran ausrichten
und darum gehört die sicherheits äußere
innere und soziale sicherheit äußere
sicherheit mit dem vermögen der dem
sondervermögen der bundeswehr aber unser
sicherheitsbegriff geht
selbstverständlich darüber hinaus darum
haben wir 40 milliarden euro zusätzlich
eingestellt für humanitäre
hilfsmaßnahmen in der ukraine
wir haben maßnahmen zur
ernährungssicherheit im bmz zusätzlich
aufgelegt wir haben für die
krisenbewältigung für wiederaufbau
infrastruktur nahezu 9 millionen euro
bereitgestellt und wir haben noch
während der bereinigungssitzung auf das
g 7 finanzministertreffen reagiert und
die liquiditätshilfen für die ukraine
werden auch mit einer milliarde aus
deutschland unterstützt darum ist diese
äußere sicherheit prägend für diesen
haushalt wie wir es lange nicht gehabt
haben aber wir hatten auch die innere
sicherheit die innere sicherheit indem
wir beispielsweise
zählstellen zusätzlich beim zoll
schaffen um die bekämpfung der
geldwäsche und steuerbetrug und auch die
im oktober auf 12 euro erhöhte
einführung des mindestlohns zu bekämpfen
wir bauen aus die extremismus prävention
und die haben auch leben gezogen aus dem
urteil in dem der unimog und die
regionalstellen des thw stärken weil wir
so zukünftig mit dem was wir zu
befürchten haben eben mehr leben rechnen
und für unsere zeit hat sie ganz wichtig
die soziale sicherheit die wir stärken
werden mit den entlastungs paketen die
wir sehr schnell sehr differenziert auf
den weg gebracht haben und so schaffen
wir sicherheit im wandel mit diesen 30
heitz begriffen und wir sind
gleichzeitig in diesem haushalt aber
auch schon in der lage dass wir
investitionen in die zukunft anschieben
indem wir langfristige perspektiven aus
st wir haben zum internationalen
klimaschutz noch etwas draufgelegt wir
haben die investitionen für die lng
terminals begonnen und haben
verpflichtungsermächtigungen eingestellt
und ich bin total froh dass wir es
geschafft haben die polarstern zwei
anzuschieben zu finanzieren endlich da
eine sicherheit zu schaffen dass die
gebaut werden kann und herr merz wies
die da sitzen sehe und ihre rede
angewandt möchte ich einfach ergänzen zu
der kritik die man surfen von meinem
vorrednerin vorrednern zu der frage der
reflektion und auch der selbstkritik der
schwarz geführten häuser der sechs
letzten 16 jahre angeht die polarstern
zweifel ein weiteres beispiel dass
begegnet uns immer wieder wo wir einfach
italy sierung haben die nicht vor banken
sind es gab immer das versprechen die
polarstern kommt aber es war 0 im
haushalt eingestellt 0 eine milliarde
mindestens müssen wir damit rechnen und
das haben wir jetzt auf den weg gebracht
meine damen und herren ganz zum
abschließen habe ich gehört es auch in
die generaldebatte dass wir als
abgeordneten den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern in den fraktionen in der ag
haushalt in den ferraris in unseren
büros aber auch in den ministerien
denken denn wir hätten die beratungen
nicht so vollziehen können wenn ich auch
die nachtschichten und
wochenendschichten eingesetzt hätten
darum ein herzlicher dank ich freue mich
auf die beratung zum 3 das einzige
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin luise amtsberg
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
dieser haushalt hat ja besonders im
kulturbüro politischen bereich
eigentlich zwei herausforderungen zu
meistern
er muss nach zwei jahren kann dem niveau
die belange von kunst und
kulturschaffenden immer wieder den
hintergrund geraten sind und politik
nicht angemessen oder viel zu spät auch
die lebenslagen von kulturschaffenden
reagiert hat vertrauen zurückgewinnen
das zum einen und zum anderen muss er
auch die idee ein herausforderungen
reagieren die ja eine über so viele
jahre andauernde auf einseitige
kulturpolitik verursacht hat und ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass wir das mit
diesem haushalt sehr gut hinbekommen dem
ein ganzes stück näher zu kommen
unsere demokratie lebt vom freier kunst
von meinungsfreiheit und weil das so ist
müssen wir auch einen beitrag dazu
leisten dass gleichberechtigung und
chancengleichheit im kulturbereich
gefördert werden diese koalition hat
sich deshalb vorgenommen die entstehung
von räumen zu unterstützen in denen ganz
unterschiedliche menschen ihre
künstlerischen ausdrucksformen finden
stärken und zeigen können und natürlich
ist das nicht für jeden und jede die
opernbühne das schauspielhaus oder das
museum es sind die proberäume im
ländlichen raum umsonst und draußen
festivals clubs oder graffiti wände die
kulturräume an denen in unserem land
eigentlich jeden tag die kunstfreiheit
gelebt wird und ich freue mich
ich freue mich dass wir mit der
unterstützung für die musikfestival c o
pop jazz und pop kultur berlin diesem
auftrag auch nachbarn kulturförderung
heißt aber auch die vielfältigen
lebensrealitäten abzubilden so
unterschiedlich wie menschen in unserem
land leben und lieben und arbeiten so
wichtig ist es eben diese vielfalt auch
in filmen büchern oder auch den bühnen
zu zeigen gerade für junge menschen um
sich zu identifizieren mit
gesellschaftspolitischen fragen mit
ideen und auch mit hoffnung und deswegen
fördern wir die s-group ein
zusammenschluss kleiner film festivals
in ganz deutschland wir stärken die
ökologische und nachhaltige kulturarbeit
und natürlich auf die kinos und weil wir
leider gottes gerade im filmbereich
wirklich erleben mussten dass die
notwendigen reformen aus den letzten
jahren verschleppt wurden werden wir uns
natürlich auch in dieser legislatur die
filmförderung endlich vornehmen und auch
solide und nachhaltige füße stellen
die kolleginnen kollegen auch sehr
schmerzhafte weise haben tontechnikerin
filmemacher musikerinnen und werbeleute
während der pandemie zu spüren bekommen
wie wenig wissen und aufmerksamkeit in
der politik für die vielfältigen arbeits
und lebensrealitäten in den
unterschiedlichen kultur branche
herrschen das muss sich dringend ändern
und zwar auch losgelöst von der pandemie
mit der förderung des bündnis der
popkultur die eine vertretung für ganz
verschiedene akteurinnen im bereich der
popmusik ist setzen wir eben mehr als
nur ein zeichen wir werden popkultur
endlich strukturell fördern nicht über
ihre köpfe hinweg sondern mit ihnen
gemeinsam mit genauso groß kulturpolitik
auch funktionieren
abschließend diese beispiele zeigen ganz
konkret wo der unterschied dieser ampel
koalition zu vorher liegt nämlich kultur
in all ihrer vielfalt ihren
unterschiedlichen ausdrucks und
organisationsformen zu fördern und damit
gleichermaßen auch den kulturbegriff
endlich ein stück zu weiten dieser
haushalt ist ein guter auftakt dafür
einen neuanfang für das dringend
notwendige umdenken und anders handeln
in der kulturpolitik herzlichen dank
luise amtsberg ist beauftragte für
menschenrechte der bundesregierung aber
sitzt auch weiterhin im ausschuss für
kultur und medien also in diesem etat
werden zwei ihrer politikfelder
behandelt stefan seiler spricht als
nächstes im er ist fraktionslose wahl
mitglied der südschleswigsche
wählerverband
für den ssw ist dieser haushalt ein
gutes zeichen in schweren zeiten
denn überall auf der welt werden
minderheiten ausgegrenzt und verfolgt
häufig sogar zu tode bedroht die
enthüllungen über den umgang der
chinesischen diktatur mit den uiguren
führt uns das ausmaß der gewalt vor
augen daraus müssen wir in unseren
beziehungen zur volksrepublik klare
konnte
bei uns in deutschland leben
minderheiten frei dennoch erfahren etwa
roma und sinti noch immer
diskriminierung doch mit dem
vorliegenden haushalt stellt die
bundesregierung sich dem entgegen und
erhöht die bundesmittel zur förderung
der 4 bei uns beheimatet minderheiten
als vertreter der friesischen
volksgruppe und der dänischen minderheit
als fürsprecher für alle unsere
minderheiten hierzulande möchte ich den
mitgliedern des hauses ganz herzlich
danken die dieses ermöglicht haben
die koalition hat hier den richtigen weg
eingeschlagen und wird ihn in den
kommenden jahren offen licht auch weiter
verfolgen lieber ampelkoalition wo es
aber nicht gibt gibt es auch schatten
ich zähle zu euren zu ihren
unterstützern aber inzwischen ist fast
ein halbes jahr vergangen und bislang
bleibt der bleibt die fortschritts
koalition hinter den geweckten
erwartungen zurück ich weiß dass der
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine die
pandemie steigende energie- und
lebenshaltungskosten die kräfte binden
aber wie so viele andere bürgerinnen und
bürger in unserem land hoffentlich dass
bald der turbo gezündet wird trotz der
großen herausforderungen brauchen wir in
den alten trott trippelschritte
zurückzufallen es fertig es fehlt der
schwung stadt zuversicht ist the german
angst zurück bei neuen ideen und
visionen geht es immer erst darum warum
etwas nicht geht und projekte werden
zerredet digitalisierung mobilitäts
wende entrümpelung der verwaltung
brauchen doch mutigen fortschritte doch
während es bei manchen themen nur
schleppend vorangeht drohen wir trotz
ihrer ambitionierten klimapolitik im
selben bereich teilweise sogar
rückschritte zu tätigen so sollen stein
und braunkohlekraftwerke nun doch auf
jahre hin reserve erhalten bleiben im
wattenmeer soll nach gas und öl gebohrt
werden man kann nicht stets vom ausstieg
aus den fossilen brennstoffen sprechen
und dann immer wieder entscheidungen
treffen die deutschland an kohle öl und
gas auf jahre binden
ich hatte gehofft dass wir zusammen den
blick noch etwas mehr auf die lösung aus
dem norden richten mehr
bürgerbeteiligung schnellere und
effizientere prozesse vertrauen in die
selbstständigkeit der bürgerinnen und
bürger stärkung regionaler strukturen
aber da sind wir noch nicht angekommen
aber ich habe dennoch das vertrauen
darauf dass die ampel koalition willen
und potenzial hat auch über die
vorliegen über den vorliegenden guten
haushalt hinaus die richtigen reformen
zu verfolgen die unser land so dringend
braucht viel
applaus auch von den anderen fraktionen
für den fraktionslosen
stefan seidler einziges mitglied hier im
deutschen bundestag aus dem
südschleswigschen
wählerverband nächste rednerin ist linda
teuteberg für die fdp fraktion und
mitglied im innenausschuss
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ein zukunftszentrum für
deutsche einheit und europäische
transformation auch um dieses projekt
geht es in dieser zeit die kommission 30
jahre friedliche revolution und deutsche
einheit hat es vorgeschlagen und die
koalition hält an diesem vorhaben fest
wird es jetzt umsetzen wir brauchen
darüber eine gesamtdeutsche debatte auch
im lichte der aktuellen
herausforderungen und das ist ein
gesamtdeutsches kein ostdeutsches
anliegen dieses zentrum zu verwirklichen
und darüber zu sprechen was es leisten
kann und muss
es gab gerade angesichts des krieges den
russland gegen die ukraine führt auch
aktuelle debatten beiträge dazu was
dieses zentrum leisten muss da war zum
teil gerede von
bedenken dass es zu einer nationalen
nabelschau kommen könnte versus der
europäischen der gesamteuropäischen und
auch stärker nach mittel- und osteuropa
gerichteten perspektive liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist kein
entweder-oder wir brauchen beides wir
brauchen die innere einheit und den
gemeinsamen anti totalitären konsens
gesamtdeutsch und gesamteuropäisch und
darum geht es auch bei diesem zentrum
denn
auch die auch geschichtspolitische
kriegserklärung putins muss eine auf
geschichtspolitische fundierte
verteidigung unserer liberalen ordnen
folgen
die dazu müssen wir uns auch damit
beschäftigen mit der geschichte vor 1989
mit dem beitrag zum beispiel den unsere
polnischen nachbarn für diesen kampf um
selbstbestimmung gegen diktatur
geleistet haben und wenn wir uns
übrigens auch mit den fehleinschätzungen
deutsche außenpolitik in den letzten
jahren beschäftigen dann lohnt es sich
auch mal stellungnahmen bundesdeutscher
politiker anfang der 80er jahre zum
solidarisch und ihrer rolle sich
anzusehen wir haben da viel
aufzuarbeiten für eine einsame
europäische zukunft und wer übrigens mal
an die worte von donald rumsfeld über
altes und neues europa denkt die sollten
uns zum nachdenken anregen genauso ein
konsens der uns geeinten europa vorgehen
lässt den brauchen wir
dazu
ist die
hatte cit auseinandersetzung mit unserer
geschichte gesamtdeutsch und
gesamteuropäische dieses zentrum leisten
soll ein beitrag
wir müssen gemeinsam außen und
sicherheitspolitisch auf erwachsen
werden und wenn in den letzten jahren
manchmal auch zu wahlkampfzwecken
wichtige themen wie das nato 2 prozent
ziehen oder auch titel für ein bisschen
schnellen anti trump applaus
instrumentalisiert wurden dann geht es
jetzt auch zu sehen der gesinnung
städtischen klarheit und rhetorik gerade
auch in den aktuellen fragen dass die
ukraine unterstützt wird dass wir um die
europäische freiheit hier gemeinsam
kämpfen dem muss auch das
verantwortungslose handeln in der praxis
folgen und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die abstimmung über die
angemessene ausstattung unserer
bundeswehr bieten jedem und jeder von
uns dazu gelegenheit zu zeigen dass wir
diese botschaft verstanden haben und an
den vielen dank
in der trotte berg war das für die
fdp-fraktion und auf sie folgt nun sepp
müller der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
jetzt fast ein halbes jahr her dass uns
staatsminister schneider deutschen
bundestag seine politischen schwerpunkte
vorgestellt hat es waren große worte zur
schaffung des amtes eines
staatsministers für ostdeutschland ich
zitiere
das ist ein klares bekenntnis von olaf
scholz für die region für ostdeutschland
und es ist eine klare verpflichtung der
bundesregierung
dieser entscheidung etwas folgen zu
lassen das heißt sie können uns daran
tatsächlich messen lassen ende des
zitats
das war die messlatte die sie
staatsminister schneider damals selbst
gesetzt hat und wenn wir heute
zwischenbilanz ziehen dann fällt diese
ernüchternd aus klar ist wir leben durch
den brutalen angriffs krieg russlands in
einer neuen zeitrechnung die
herausforderung für die europäische
union und deutschland sind gewaltig die
herausforderungen sind insbesondere in
ostdeutschland mit den händen zu greifen
zu einem der dringlichsten megathemen
gehört die teuerung in den regalen in
den supermärkten ein halbes pfund butter
kostet mittlerweile drei eur 29 die
bundesregierung steht in der pflicht die
bezahlbare energieversorgung in ganz
deutschland herr schneider zu
gewährleisten die bundesregierung steht
in der pflicht gut bezahlte
arbeitsplätze zu sichern es geht darum
die attraktivität unseres
wirtschaftsstandortes für
großinvestitionen wie tesla und intel
hoch zu halten sehr geehrter herr
staatsminister die menschen in leuna und
schwedt machen sich seit geraumer zeit
große sorgen beide raffinerien sind die
lebensadern zu einer energiesicherheit
zu einer gut bezahlbare energie
versicherungen ostdeutschlands die
anspannung vor ort war besonders in den
vergangenen tagen mit händen zu spüren
auch war die kritik der finanzministerin
aus brandenburg kathrin lange im übrigen
eine sozialdemokraten am kurs von
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck mehr
als deutlich keine entscheidung ins
blaue hinein
weiterbetrieb versorgung und
bezahlbarkeit müssen verbindlich
gesichert sein
es ist schon so sehr geehrter herr
staatsminister
zu krisenzeiten schlägt die stunde der
regierung aber umso wichtiger ist es
jetzt dass die menschen in
ostdeutschland einen
durchsetzungsstarken fürsprecher für die
belange in der bundesregierung an ihrer
seite haben
jemanden der in der bundesregierung für
den osten die strippen zieht wo ist er
klares bekenntnis herr schneider dass
wir den eu ratsbeschluss zum eu zum öl
embargo eins zu eins umsetzen wo ist ihr
klares bekenntnis dass russisches öl
durch die truppe zumindest für schwedt
weiterhin genutzt werden kann wo bleibt
ihr ein forderung dass der bundeskanzler
olaf scholz endlich zu einem großen
nationalen energiegipfel einlädt wo ist
mehr bezahlbarer
ihr bekenntnis für bezahlbaren sprit in
ost und west wir ja das ist klar dass es
bei den grünen großer große zwischenruf
er fordert und herausforderte meiner
circa 5% spät hat und noch weniger
wahlergebnisse produziert die leute vor
ort haben existenz da sind 30 jährige
junge frauen und männer hatten ihre
familienschicksale darauf ausgerichtet
haben und ihre bundesregierung sagt
denen nichts und bündnis 90 die grünen
sagten wohl von robert habeck da kriegen
wir schon sehr süß und kind ja wie sieht
denn die lösung aus wie wollen sie den
30-jährigen erzählen die gerade mit
ihrem zweijährigen kind dieses jahr eine
hausfinanzierung gemacht haben das ende
des jahres kein arbeitsplatz mehr druck
zur verfügung steht wenn ihr keine
lösung haben und vom staatsminister
schneider für ostdeutschland kommt dazu
nichts wir brauchen jemanden in der
bundesregierung der zum hörer greift er
sich gegen den wirtschaftsminister
durchsetzt wenn es um existenzielle
fragen einer bezahlbaren und sicheren
energieversorgung
ostdeutschland auf der politischen
agenda zu stehen hat wie viel soll das
halbe von brutto ostdeutschen regalen
noch kosten bis diese bundesregierung
endlich aufwacht ich sage es offen
heraus ich finde es enttäuschend dass
sich der staatsminister für
ostdeutschland bei dieser für uns so
wichtigen debatte nahezu
vollständig weggeduckt hat quatsch es
spricht bände dass in den vergangenen
tagen so viele menschen in lollar und
besonders in schwedt von existenziellen
ängsten geplagt sind der für
ostdeutschland zuständige staatsminister
nicht tag und nacht in der
regierungszentrale arbeitet um lösung
anzubieten wo ist der staatsminister
niebel sozialdemokratie ihr
staatsminister hat ist wichtiger
gehalten in den letzten tagen an einem
fußballturnier im finnischen lahti teil
zu nehmen anstatt den ostdeutschen
antwort auf die drängenden fragen zu
geben das ist der respekt des
staatsministers gegenüber dem osten sehr
geehrter herr steigung sz ihnen
offensichtlich an respekt gegenüber den
betroffenen menschen in leuna und
schwedt es fehlt ihnen offensichtlich an
demut vor dem an und es fehlt ihnen
offensichtlich an politischer und
durchsetzungsfähigkeit wenn es für den
osten darauf ankommt liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen es ist richtig liebe linda
teuteberg dass das transformations-
zentrum endlich kommt es ist richtig
weil wir als großen koalition bereits
das fundament in der letzten wahlperiode
dazu gelegt haben doch wo ist und es ist
richtig dass die transformation auch
osteuropa mit in den blick nimmt doch wo
ist jetzt der respekt den osteuropäer
und gegenüber polen liefert an die
ukraine panzer und hat von unserer
bundesregierung ersatz versprochen
bekommen ich zitiere tatsächlich haben
wir ein solches versprechen auch
bekommen und deutschland hat versprochen
uns diese panzer zu liefern sie haben
dieses versprechen nicht erfüllt
offen gesagt wir sind sehr enttäuscht
darüber dass sagt kein geringerer als
polens präsident andré duda wer
ostdeutsche interessen warnen wer weiter
scharniere sein will zwischen ost und
westeuropa der muss auch mit den
osteuropäischen staaten sprechen und
dass es ihre aufgabe
herr staatsminister dieser kommen sie
nicht nach daran sind sie bereits
gescheitert ihre messlatte ist gerissen
danke
sepp müller war das ungewohnt laut hat
er hier den ostbeauftragten der
bundesregierung carsten schneider
angegriffen auch sepp müller kennt sich
natürlich da aus ist selber aus sachsen
anhalt
und in nächster redner in der debatte
ist mit krücken helgeland spd fraktion
sprecher für kultur und medien
frau präsidentin liebe kollegen pflegen
[Musik]
2,29 milliarden und weitere maßnahmen
für kultur warum
kultur ist aus der sicht der koalition
nicht zwangsbeglücken nicht
reparaturbetrieb nicht ornament bei
bedarf sondern recht und anspruch auf
kulturelle teilhabe und das verkörpert
mit diesem offenen geist unsere kultur
staatsministerin roth
kultur
ist im übrigen auch erinnerung und nicht
kunst der amnesie und selbst amnestie
des oppositionsführers märz um das
einmal deutlich zu machen kunst und
kultur heißt auch arbeit und das
bedeutet stärkung der
künstlersozialkasse das bedeutet
anständige honorare das bedeutet
mindestlohn rare mindestvergütung
kunst und kultur heißt auch die
ukrainische
kulturnation identität und sprache am
leben zu halten ihre räume zu geben und
sie zu verteidigen gegen die versuche
der kulturellen auslöschung des mutigen
regimes und gegen den genozid von mario
pohl und es heißt zu erinnern an den
völkermörder rischen hole mutter auch
das heißt kultur
kultur bedeutet aber auch im sinne
dieser demokratie
der deutsche buchpreis für stefan
marcinowski und damit ein demokratischer
schlag ins gesicht der slap
einschüchterung strategie der
hohenzollern gegen journalistinnen und
journalisten und gegen die
geschichtspolitik und dem
geschichtsrevisionismus
der hohenzollern und dann apropos
kultur heißt auch bei allem verständnis
für profilieren und selbstprofilierung
kultur heißt auch kultur des umgangs
miteinander und heißt nicht dem
bundeskanzler olaf scholz
geschichtsrevisionismus vorzuwerfen und
damit den tatsächlichen unerträglichen
geschichtsrevisionismus der rechten und
rechtspopulisten tagtäglich in diesem
lande zu verharmlosen und zu
bagatellisieren
in diesem sinne stehen wir als koalition
für eine kultur in der menschen sprechen
und wie nicht für menschen sprechen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
und wir kommen langsam zum ende dieser
generalaussprache
christiane china allein ist die
vorletzte rednerin cdu/csu-fraktion
präsidentin mit kolleginnen und kollegen
nach zwei jahren durststrecke kommt das
kulturleben in unserem land endlich
wieder zurück das berliner
theatertreffen findet statt eröffnung
der festspiele mecklenburg-vorpommern
rock am ring viele künstler gehen wieder
auf tournee die zahl der veranstaltungen
steigt auf rekordniveau aber trotz
dieser öffnung story bleiben die zeiten
unkalkulierbar deshalb braucht die
kultur jetzt genau zwei dinge
planbarkeit und verlässlichkeit die
verlängerung des neustadt programms ist
daher richtig aber nicht ausreichend
zwölf monate sind schnell um und es
bedarf einer evaluierung der sonderfonds
für den ausfall von veranstaltungen muss
dringend entbürokratisiert werden und
vor allem der realität angepasst werden
und leider gibt es immer noch kein
ansprechpartner der bundesregierung für
die kultur und kreativwirtschaft
ganz entgegen den ankündigungen im
koalitionsvertrag die branche wartet
händeringend darauf bisher vergeblich
neue personalstellen würden hingegen
schon geschafft geschaffen allein 18 bei
der bundesbeauftragten unsere
verlässlichkeit gehört auch das nicht
gekürzt wird und das haben sie gemacht
und zwar bei projektförderungen wie zum
beispiel eine vertrieben nennen oder
aber allein 75 millionen euro bei der
auswärtigen kulturpolitik dabei haben
sie frau roth auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz noch betont
kulturpolitik ist sicherheitspolitik das
passt dann aber nicht zusammen denn
jetzt wird beide programme arbeit der
kulturvermittler und den auslandsschulen
der rotstift angesetzt
stattdessen werden sieben millionen euro
und das neue programm globaler süden
gesteckt ohne dass ein konzept vor die
wir wissen gar nicht wofür diese mit in
diesem jahr nach ausgegeben werden
sollen und deshalb wollten wir dieses
geld der hat er musik zugute kommen
lassen aber das hat die ampel leiter
abgelehnt und erst am wochenende konnten
wir beim deutschen chorfest in leipzig
mit 350 chören erleben wie eindrucksvoll
amateur musik sein kann und sie waren
dabei verraten
auch als der präsident des deutschen
chorverbands christian wulff ermahnte
ich zitiere ohne stärkere politische
unterstützung über die chorszene die
groner krise nicht bewältigen
es gibt auch vorhaben die haben
parteiübergreifende unterstützung dazu
gehört dass denkmalschutz sonderprogramm
und auch das zukunftsprogramm kino wir
stärken damit den ländlichen raum und
das ist ein kernanliegen unserer
fraktion daher sind die zusätzlichen
zehn millionen euro für die notwendigen
investitionen kinos gut angelegt
allerdings nehmen sie den 100 forum
dafür fünf millionen euro weg dem
größten nationalen kulturprojekte und
das ist der falsche weg anstatt ist
chefsache zu machen erklären sie es
öffentlich so riesenbaustelle meine
fraktion meine kollegin hat bereits
ausgeführt war gestern sehr beeindruckt
und was er entscheidend ist wir stehen
ganz klar zum kreuz und einen
gemeinsamen besuch im humboldt-forum
kann ich daher nur sehr empfehlen die
auswirkungen der pandemie
auch die kultur hat nicht nur eine
kulturpolitische sie hat vor allem auch
eine wirtschaftliche soziale und
gesellschaftliche dimension
umsatzeinbrüche von bis zu 80 prozent
allein 20 20 ein verlust von 15
milliarden euro in der kreativwirtschaft
haben viele beschäftigte mussten sich um
orientieren und fehlen jetzt und daher
ist die soziale situation der
künstlerinnen und künstler durchaus ganz
oben auf der agenda ihrem erklärten
willen das voranzutreiben müssen taten
folgen wir werden da genau hinschauen
zum beispiel müssen wir im blick haben
auf die erhöhung des bundeszuschusses
ausreichen wird kultur muss bezahlbar
bleiben das gilt für die unternehmer
aber es wird vor allen dingen auch für
die einzelnen und die inflation darf auf
gar keinen fall dazu führen
dass es für familien nicht mehr möglich
ist ein kulturerlebnis wahrzunehmen die
ob der ukraine krieg und die inflation
überschatten das politische
tagesgeschäft und fließen
selbstverständlich auch in die
kulturpolitik 1 daraus resultieren
zusätzliche aufgaben die auch von der
kultur staatsministerin angegeben
angegangen werden müssen das darf aber
keine entschuldigung dafür sein um die
grundlagen der kulturpolitik zu
vernachlässigen die ampel koalition hat
einen ambitionierten koalitionsvertrag
vorgelegt er gilt es jetzt umzusetzen
aber aktuell kommen sie über den ideen
status nicht hinaus künstler
kulturschaffende und kreative
benötigen jetzt die sicherheit und
verlässlichkeit hatten die mieter
nicht im stich und sorgen sie dafür dass
die kulturelle vielfalt auch in den
kommenden jahren sicher gestellt wird
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich grüße
sie sehr herzlich an diesem vormittag
und darf als letzten redner in dieser
debatte das wort für bündnis 90/die
grünen abgeordneten stefan gelbhaar
geben
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren nun soll es
noch einmal um den haushalt des
ost-beauftragten gehen ich möchte sie
eingangs auf eine merkwürdigkeit
hinweisen sie alle kennen die
süddeutsche zeitung
sie alle kennen die radiowellen des
norddeutschen rundfunks oder den
westdeutschen rundfunk wdr was sie nicht
kennen ist ein ostdeutscher hombruch
oder in der ostdeutsche zeitung und das
ist für sich schon bemerkenswert
gleichwohl fordere ich hier wieder die
neugründung einer zeitung oder eines
rundfunks aber explizite und
ausdrückliche begegnungs und diskussions
räume fielen im osten mit dem
zukunftszentrum für deutsche einheit und
europäische transformation wird ein
solcher ort geschaffen und das ist auch
notwendig
noch immer lässt sich das gebiet der ddr
einen demographischen karten gut
erkennen etwa wenn es um die ältesten
regionen in deutschland geht oder um die
höhe der erbschaftsteuer bei impfquoten
bei einkommen und vermögen bei der
zustimmung zu waffenlieferungen bei
ärztliche versorgung und bei vielen
vielen mehr ja auch hier gut von der
ampel koalition gearbeitet etwa mit der
erhöhung des mindestlohns oder der
finanzierung des härtefallfonds aber die
baustellen sind
aber die baustellen sind nicht weniger
geworden die debatte um die industrie
und industrialisierung des ostens ist
geschichtlich hoch relevant war das ein
planvoller die der scherbenhaufen oder
ein planloses verscherbeln der treuhand
ich verrate ihnen was da haben beide
allerdings unterschiedliche anteile
daran politisch aktuelle aber es aber
ist die folgende frage wie konnte zum
beispiel die solar und wind branche im
osten in den letzten jahren so zugrunde
gehen conergy scat jetzt nordex in
rostock wie steht es um die repräsentanz
um die durchsetzung solcher legitime
interessen explizit ostdeutsche
reflexion räume werden gebraucht auch
außenpolitisch in ostdeutschland
in ostdeutschland repariert das
sicherheitsgefühl putins deutlich
stärker berücksichtigt aber da muss doch
das gestörte sicherheitsgefühl von polen
oder litauen
umso mehr wahrgenommen werden und die
zerstörung der ukraine für diese
notwendigen debatten um die rolle der
bundesrepublik in europa und ist
insbesondere in osteuropa braucht es
räume da sehe ich die bundesregierung in
der pflicht aber nicht nur die wirksame
sanktionen zu fordern aber ein
öl-embargo auszuschließen das muss man
erst mal in einem satz unterbringen frau
die da sitzen sie dann da sitzen die
dann in einem boot mit orban ungarn und
teilen der ost-cdu ich frage mich ist
das wirklich links unser
wirtschaftliches
unser wirtschaftsminister hatte einen
klaren kurs wir brauchen neue
erneuerbare aufgaben für 40 jahren
spielt oder auch inliner das ist der weg
vielen dank
vielen das war also die
generalaussprache
und wir kommen damit erst einmal gibt es
hier eine abstimmung also die zweite
lesung war das ja und dann die
schlussabstimmung führt dann erst am
freitag erfolgen das gibt mir die
gelegenheit etwas zum nächsten
einzelplan zusagen der hier besprochen
wird nämlich der einzelplan fünf das ist
der etat des auswärtigen amtes
71 milliarden euro sind für das
auswärtige amt eingeplant damit wächst
dieser etat um über 800 millionen euro
noch einmal im vergleich zu 20 21
besonders profitiert davon die
humanitäre hilfe im ausland natürlich
ist dort auch der ukraine krieg
entscheidend und auch wenn die
bundeswehr eigentlich zum
verteidigungsministerium
thematisch gezielt wird könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass in dieser debatte auch
dieses sondervermögen 100 milliarden
euro dass ja die koalition einbringen
möchte eine rolle spielt
denn
heute morgen gab es eine
ausschusssitzung dazu und die union hat
in diese abstimmung über dieses
sondervermögen erst einmal blockiert
obwohl ist ja vergangene woche eine
einigung generell dazu gab denn so hat
csu verteidigungspolitiker florian hahn
auch heute im phoenix interview gesagt
es sei zu wenig zeit gewesen um die
liste mit den rüstungsprojekten zu
prüfen und deswegen hat die union wollte
die union noch nicht darüber abstimmen
inwieweit sich dort der ausschuss zu
diesem bundeswehr sondervermögen verhält